So we could just go meta or whatever your best at.
Okay, Bogren, but wait is Bogren first matchup?
No, yeah Is it?
Yeah, he is.
You don't even know how many games are you playing anyway?
Also default is Virginia.
So we really want to fuck I don't think we should fuck with them, but All right, wait if it's default east coast, can we just like no, oh, yeah default is east coast.
Yes Then we target ban the the west coast players Oh, cool No, we target ban bogers strange and then after that wait, can I give you like insider trade?
Sure Okay, I heard bogers other tank player be like yo, I can strange you go hulk So what if we like ban hulk because i'm lowkey a strange man Oh, okay.
Okay, if you're a strange man, we can also just ban strange We protect we protect the thing because 60% win rate Yeah, yeah, hey my mic wasn't working.
Hi everybody.
Hi
Are you what I'm your healer.
No
No, he's not I can't kick him Get this guy out of here
Bring on the chaos.
Yeah.
Okay.
Bye.
Okay Sabotaging us don't worry.
I sniffed it out Therefore, where the fuck are you?
I'm my princess I'm wide among us.
You're why I don't have wide among us add me wide among us I mean add me All right, I need to add you too, yeah, it's just doki bird that's really it I am glorp fan 5 000 Okay All right.
I said Lord fan I am too blunt.
Oh, okay.
I added friend.
What is clone game wide among us?
Okay Lord fan, uh, who is missing?
Let's see Yeah I don't know who's i'm still waking up right now.
You just woke up.
Yeah, I woke up like 10 minutes ago Now we're cooked It's okay i'm playing i'm playing.
Oh, we gotta join the general.
We got a little debrief.
Oh, we got a debrief Are we allowed to regular stream?
Okay, all right i'm handing over Okay
Dude you people with the joint channel things get a grip You get a grip what do you mean?
I'm saying you people you're kind with the fucking discord things get a grip This is me Sleepy i've already had enough of you brother.
I need you I don't want to i have you i've already had enough if that guy says anything important.
Let me know I haven't blocked When did you get into this fucking tournament?
I didn't know you were here.
When did you get the whole time?
Oh my god Leave me alone
A lot happening right now, this is happening.
Hey guys.
Hey, yo, what's up?
Good morning Afternoon.
Good afternoon.
Good morning.
There's only one real time zone true
Wow Oh my god
I got quiet while we all in here for Because I don't know But I guess We're waiting still for Kyle.
They're dialing in.
They're trying way too hard right now.
Booger, you can just go in there and yell at them.
Why don't you just go guide them?
Guys, I am very tired.
We should all just join their...
Guys, I think going to bed at 4 in the morning was not a great idea.
What if we join and say our favorite Ultimate voice line?
My pick.
Can we drag them?
Born again!
Again!
While we wait, can Dana give us some LeBron James motivational quotes?
You guys listen to the A.I.
song?
The A.I.
I'm going to put it in general.
Okay.
It's not an A.I., but it's just a LeBron song.
R&B.
Oh, I thought it was a LeBron James song.
Hang on, they're here.
They're here.
Alright, everyone.
Thank you all so much for...
Guys, I'm just waking up, guys.
...joining today's tournament.
It's a very simple format.
It's a seven-team round, Robin.
You just play every team once, so everyone's guaranteed seven games.
Top two teams just does a BO3 at the very end.
You guys are playing for a prize pool of $60,000.
Wow!
By participating, each team already earns $6,000.
So, just before showing up, each of you walks away with $1,000.
Congratulations!
Yippee!
Woohoo!
$1,000.
Thank you so much, sponsors.
A big thank you to Mr. John Marvel Rivals.
Captains, you guys should know who's hosting each lobby.
It's always going to be Team A.
Try to have each other added.
We're going to go pretty quickly.
I know how annoying it is to have downtime between games in these tournaments.
So, pretty much whenever you're done, you can hop into your next one.
Any questions?
No.
What happened to our free skins from the Clone Royale?
Thank you.
The clone mode is down until tomorrow.
So, what happened to the skins?
What happened to the skins?
What did you do with the money then, bro?
I mean, it's codes.
It's not actual money.
Wait, can we have the codes now?
So, can everyone get codes now?
For the codes?
Toast, you can kick them from the tournament.
We'll figure that out later.
Everyone, you guys are all free to join your lobby whenever.
And with the remaining 10 seconds, I would like all of you to trash talk someone specific.
I don't even have to say their name when they are in my fucking brain.
You are so fucking fast.
I was in your brain without saying a word, bitch.
I'm just going to leave.
I don't even want to hear you talking anymore.
Alright, good luck, everyone.
I joined first, so no one had to hear it.
That's right.
I'm a good man.
And now it's time to lock-flank Jeff.
I need Luna buff.
Let's go.
You're just going to get fucking slam dunked by Booger.
No, I'm not.
Alright, okay, fine.
Lock in Jeff.
Let's see how it goes.
I don't even need to use my ult.
I just have to Icicle their backline.
No, believe in him.
We got a Jeff!
I'm literally playing Mystery Heroes this tournament.
Oh, by the way, I know I'm tank, but Adams might be my second best character.
If we ever need an Adam.
Oh, if we do triple support, then we'll just go Adam.
Another triple support tournament.
Oh boy, this is not your favorite, Coney.
We ran 3-3 all fucking day.
I'll do another 3-3 again.
I'll brush up on the stream.
The thing is, if I'm on support and none of you are getting healed, I'm going to use the backline.
Yeah, because why don't you just stay defense?
We run triple support with surefour on Jeff.
With surefour on Jeff and then the tank line.
We have to protect the thing because Coney loves the thing.
And he's a little... he needs the thing to function.
So, I don't know for the backline.
I mean, we could ban Mag if we want to.
Or Hulk.
We're banning Hulk, right?
For a bulger.
Yeah, I'm down.
I play Strange and Mag mostly, but I've learned the root of it.
I mean, we could do... do we do a Mag thing or a Strange thing?
Either one is alright.
Oh, so what is... Tuanto?
Is that how you pronounce your name?
Yeah.
Or you can just call me Jake.
Or Jake, okay.
Yeah, that is a lie.
I don't know if we should say who Jake plays.
We've got too many viewers here right now.
Yeah, what do you play, Jake?
But like, he cooks.
I play DPS.
What is a Bobo?
I play mostly all the hitscan ones.
Just because I'm just naming.
Yeah, just play your best DPS character, really, because it's a Creator Cup, not like a fucking actual esports tournament.
Unless Bogred tries really, really hard.
I mean, we all just play our best character, and then Surefour can play Mr. Heroes.
It's crazy that we play every team one time.
Yeah, I mean, there's seven teams.
I'm not doing best of three from seven different teams.
True.
That's way too much.
We can't adapt.
Also, Surefour, can you make the lobby for the next team?
Because I don't know how to make lobbies.
No.
What the fuck do you mean, no?
Okay, well, who knows how to make...
I will not take this delegation.
This is your captain speaking, and I'm delegating my work to you.
I'm a loose cannon.
You're a loose cannon?
Okay, well, does anyone else want to make the lobby?
Because it's a little too much responsibility for me.
I can, but I don't really know how.
Okay, I believe in you.
You can do it.
I can try.
Okay, are we all ready?
Yeah, I think we're ready now.
What's our second ban, by the way?
Is there anything we really want to ban for a second ban?
I like don't know who they play, but I don't think they know who I play.
I mean, I'll just ban Bucky, because Bucky is so overpowered, then.
Yeah, I also kind of hate Wolverine, but I don't know if we play him.
I don't think anyone on the enemy team has a good enough Wolverine, but like, obviously, it's like the most normal ban.
I'm not worried about it.
I'm on thing.
Yeah, I'm not worried about it either, and I feel like banning Bucky is like the scariest DPS at the moment.
Yeah, I'm down.
You also don't want me on Bucky.
I'll fucking throw the game.
Who has the ban?
Who has the ban thing?
It's Glorpfan.
Wait, why is it me?
It's, um...
It's whoever has... Are you in a faction?
If you are, then it usually goes to you.
Oh, yeah, I am.
Yeah, so it goes to you.
So we're banning Hulk first.
Yeah, I'm down.
And then protect the thing.
Protect the thing.
Oh, nice, he did.
Okay, we ban Namor then.
Okay, protect thing?
Protect the thing, yeah.
I just hate playing against Namor.
Why can't they click on him?
Oh, wait in front of me.
Yeah.
Wait, they're going Dive.
Oh, okay, we keep Namor.
We keep Namor.
Protect the thing.
Okay, okay, okay.
And then, well, if they're going Dive, we fucking ban Spider.
Spider-Man or Magic, I don't know if they play Spider or Magic, but we could just ban Spider.
Yeah, we could ban Spider.
Yeah.
Just ban Spider.
We ban Spider and then we have Namor against Dive.
So ban Spider.
Yeah, I almost thought I was done banning for a second.
And then if they ban Namor, then, like, I fucking...
I don't know what we could do against Dive.
Good luck, everybody.
We all fucking try to survive.
Alright, we still have Namor.
We still have Namor.
If they do have Dive, you know how to play Invis?
Lulu?
Yeah, I can do Invis.
Yeah, I mean, yeah, you can just Invis and just Invis push the Venom away.
But Cloak is alright.
I think, like, I think Invis is better than Cloak for ult-wise, though.
I think Invis is broken.
Alright, let's go!
I just need to wake up.
Where's your caffeine?
I didn't have time to make caffeine.
Where's your alarm on your phone?
What do you mean my alarm woke me up at 11.45?
Why'd you put it at 11.45?
I was really looking forward to the clone rumble.
I know!
We get free skins!
Now Toast is gonna pocket it.
The rich get richer.
Did you get your skin money for the V2 movement?
I have no idea what I'm gonna do with that.
They apparently are supposed to email you that.
That's strange.
I got it.
Oh, you got it?
There's so much.
Oh my god.
Oh, maybe I'll just check my spam.
Okay.
They have Namor.
Oh my god, I definitely wake.
I've frozen.
There's a Hawkeye on our left.
Wait, any heals?
We can?
Thank you.
I'm gonna heal behind you too.
Okay, I got you.
I'm trying to get Namor here.
Get the turrets, get the turrets.
I got him.
Just push out if you can.
Yay!
It's just Venom.
They're opening a portal.
The chip is 3-0?
It works!
I got you.
Thank you, thank you.
I need help, I need help.
I've frozen.
I've frozen, I've frozen, I've frozen.
Venom has no...
Oh no, our chip!
Is it a good ult?
I can't tell.
You ult first, Lulu.
Oh, I'm dead.
Should I go ahead and use it?
Yeah, you can use it.
I'll do it for Strange.
I'm on Venom.
I froze Venom.
I think we gotta reset.
Let's reset.
I'm resetting this.
Yeah, one sec, I had nobody to jump to.
They have Strange ult and they should have Venom ult.
Can we...
Push Strange ult?
And this?
Yeah, I'll save it.
Or like, Luna freeze.
No, no, they have Strange ult.
Luna ult is best against Strange ult.
Yeah.
Alright.
No more on the left, he's like flanking in the building.
Frozen.
Venom's still on the back here.
Yeah, they have Wraith behind us.
They have Nocturne behind us.
I'm just... Oh, I couldn't do anything.
I got one of their supports.
We have a Namor behind us.
So we can't do anything.
Do you have portal?
We could just portal, backline.
You wanna go?
Yeah, portal, backline, maybe.
Oh, not there, not there, not there!
I'm covering him, I'm covering him, I'm covering.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
They have nothing to drop though.
He's long.
He's got nobody.
Get the Luna, get the Luna!
I'm damage boosting it.
Spit me out now!
I spit you out, I spit you out.
He's flipping out of here.
Trade the turrets again.
I'm trying to help you.
Thank you.
Venom, Venom 1, Venom 1, Venom 1!
Strange, strange, nice.
They're gonna have portal, so...
No, they're waiting, they're waiting.
Alright, go Sherford, go!
I'm going, I'm going.
Go Sherford, go!
I see the smallest shark fin through the wall.
It's so funny.
It's adorable.
Nice.
They have a low key.
They have a low key, yeah.
Mag now.
What if I just give my snowflake to our shark?
I'll call strange.
In a strange mirror?
Come on, man.
Venom in the back, he's about to die.
Venom, Venom, Venom 1, we can burn Venom.
No, nevermind.
Yeah, Neymar's up top.
Coney, Coney, you're by yourself, careful.
I got it.
There's still Neymar above us.
Yeah, sorry.
No, I had a good lineup, but it's only because everybody else was there.
Yeah, yeah, we were being terrorized.
All good, all good.
Where's our shark?
Can we walk up?
Yeah.
I'm low.
There is a Neymar behind us.
There is a Neymar behind us and Venom.
Nice, here we go, here we go.
I might need to go Mag here.
Damage.
Yeah, I pushed out way too far on that.
I have my ult too.
I almost had my ult.
Oh my gosh, shit.
We have to get this Neymar off of high ground.
Trevor, can you get that Neymar off of high ground?
Mmm.
Oh wait, you're a Neymar.
Oh nevermind, I thought you were a shark still.
Nah.
I got one up there, I can't get it.
I froze him again.
We're still here.
Do you want to...
Invis first if you have to.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I don't think our heal is gonna heal us right now.
Yeah.
I might need heals here.
Can you look at me?
Thank you.
I'm gonna go ahead and use mine here.
Okay.
Oh nice, they didn't get it correctly.
I got their Luna.
We need both, we need both!
Neymar dead.
Okay, I'm damage boosting.
Focus on Mag, he's on the cart.
Yeah, I'm looking at Mag.
We can't progress without him.
Okay, nice.
We have no support else here.
Okay.
Wait, Surefour, where are you?
I can give you an orb.
I'm right here.
I got ult, I might just push up and force it.
Just to get that wall down.
I can portal this door, but...
I mean, you have to portal it now.
We can.
Nevermind, you can't, you can't, you can't.
I froze him.
Nice.
I got their Neymar.
I'm dropping.
Last fight.
I froze him, I froze him.
Oh, I got shot.
You only have two heals.
Make sure you're on the cart too.
Yeah.
I'm at 10%.
The Neymar is up top, trying to get me.
No heals yet, no heals yet, I'm coming over now.
I'm dead.
Not the squid.
I know, it's the squid.
Okay, we always ban Neymar.
I cannot heal a fucking Neymar.
No, he is.
Decent push.
Not a bad push.
Yeah, Neymar is just flanking.
I can just give Surefour the snowflake to contest the Neymar.
Wait,
can we Neymar or no?
Surefour can play Neymar.
I need like...
Caffeine in my nose.
It's okay, my eyes are...
Snort G-Fuel.
Dust your eyeballs a little bit.
Dust my eyeballs.
Quickest path to your brain.
Oh shit.
It's the first game.
Only thing, let's calm if we are distracted.
Unless I'm trying to figure out if there is shit on you guys.
Yeah, I always freeze a Venom.
So unless I freeze a Venom, we can just turn around and kill him.
I'll go Mag if we lose first.
I think Neymar is like being very obnoxious.
Yeah, I think Mag is the better tank with the thing.
That was comedy.
I got you.
He missed the dive.
Oh, he shielded it.
Venom on, Venom on, Venom on.
Behind us Neymar, behind us Neymar, behind us Neymar.
I need heals.
Venom is coming up.
Venom diving.
Frozen Venom, frozen Venom, frozen.
Oh, we have to get out of this Neymar.
I think I got locked.
Jesus Christ.
I wasn't even close.
Fuck man, my bad.
We need someone to turn around for that Neymar.
I can portal us here.
Yeah, portal us.
I got their Venom.
Yeah, we are portaling, we are portaling.
I don't know if Venom is going to come and drop.
We'll body block.
I killed Venom.
Someone touch point, someone touch point.
I got it.
It's fine, it's fine, we got the touch point.
Neymar, Neymar, Neymar on point, Neymar on point.
Probably a reset.
I'm still there.
I'm getting... no way.
Melted.
I think, I don't know which...
I think like...
Jake, you might have to contest the Neymar.
If you can.
Because he's always going to be flanking since that's what Neymar players do.
Mhmm.
So we need at least one person.
Venom is on me in the back.
Alright, I can't push up.
So they give you Snowflake.
Your powers are mine!
Got bubbled.
We have to push up soon.
Thank you.
Alright, I have to pop this to push up.
We gotta push up here with it.
Yep.
I'm on my way back.
Venom's still back here.
I'm fine.
Holy shit.
Boggers on me!
I don't have freeze because of him.
I got two.
Boggers still...
Boggers is on our backline right now.
Venom's on our backline too.
I'm 10% to my ult.
I'm trying to survive as long as I can here.
Wait, Coney's coming in.
Just touch one hand.
I'm just trying to hold Coney as long as I can.
Alright, at least we know.
We bad name Roy.
Honestly?
GG, nice try.
It's just the first game.
It's the first game of the day.
Yeah, I'm not even awake.
Okay, I know he's a better player than me, but I get to say that I made Boggers switch off Strange in the mirror.
He did.
He had to go mag.
That's cringe meta.
All good.
DM for Glorp.
We just couldn't handle flankers.
I think next ban, we just ban Namor because he's just a good flanker character.
Yeah.
What's their comp if they have other flankers?
Oh, they have other flankers.
Namor is supposed to deal with flankers.
Or he flanks himself.
It really depends on who has the... which Namor flanks first basically.
I was getting picks on their Luna.
He was doing the same thing to his team, but the enemy team also had a Venom to help with the flanker as well, but we only have frontline.
So I think Coney just has to turn around and protect the backline.
Coney or Jake has to deal with the flanker.
You have to just 1v1.
Wait, do I have to make a lobby now?
Yeah, you make the lobby for the next one.
DM for Glorp.
Depends if their game is done or not.
Yeah, but we have to make the lobby first anyway, so... Why don't we just stay in this lobby and then just switch?
Oh, that's true.
We can steal their lobby.
Or wait, but Bogren might stay in his lobby though.
No, they already all left.
Oh, they all left?
Alright, we kidnapped this lobby.
My lobby now!
Can you re-invite me?
I left the lobby.
Yeah, I got you.
Who am I fighting next?
I don't even know.
Oh, Mendo's team.
We're fighting Mendo's team next.
I think... I think we're done?
I think?
We'll see.
They're not... It doesn't say in-game so that's not... Oh yeah, they got rolled apparently.
Oh, nice.
Okay, let's... By Timmy's stack team.
Oh yeah, Timmy's team is pretty stacked, yeah.
Oh yeah, they're here.
I don't even know who we're playing against.
Mendo's team, which would be...
Fuck, what is it?
XQC, Taxi, JDOTB, Pico, Buddha.
What's the map?
Wait, who has... Am I the one that has access to... Oh, I do.
What is the map?
I don't even know what the map is.
Hell's Heaven, okay.
Guys, I don't know how to do this.
Oh, there it is.
Where the fuck is Hell's Heaven?
Am I stupid?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Hell's Heaven.
Are y'all alright?
Um, we ban Groot.
We have... I'm down.
Yeah, my Groot's pretty good.
Well, I don't know if I want to call a tank.
No, XQC is a Groot one trick.
We ban Groot.
Unless Shortfur wants to play Wolverine against his Groot.
Probably not.
Alright, then we do Groot name war.
We might go Rocket Punisher, but that's alright.
I think we'll be okay, question mark.
We know you are Truss.
Your team's not even that stacked.
What's happening?
It's okay, I have a back brain debuff.
He's just saying, implying our team is really stacked.
Well, I'm like...
What do you mean?
I'm literally just waking up.
We have two Genshin players and a Smash player.
I don't know, I think also because he has a thing against Code right now.
I haven't played Smash in five years, bro.
I'm a YouTube watcher.
I play Smash.
Oh yeah, you're the Smash player.
Genshin is like aim.
It's like riding a bike.
That's crazy.
Oh no, they aren't ready yet.
I think they're also not happy of getting enrolled by Timmy's team.
We gotta lock in.
Oh my god.
Honestly, also, if they have Dive and Coney can Magneto, I could add him and then we do a solo tank Mag.
I don't think this team's gonna play Dive.
Yeah, no, this team's not.
I'm also down to just hug backline more.
I was in frontline mode.
Yeah, Coney, yeah.
When they have Dive, just jump back to us if you can or do Mag Strange.
Sure.
We know you are.
Like, what?
You know, XQ2's always mad.
I know.
It's just silly.
Alright, we do...
Who has it?
Okay, Glorpfan.
You ban Groot.
But they're banning first.
Ban Groot, protect the thing.
Do you think they ban Thing?
Oh, well, Coney...
Coney likes the thing.
Magneto.
They might, okay, they might be doing infinite ammo punisher.
They might be doing infinite ammo punisher then if they ban Magneto.
Yeah, they could be.
We could ban Rocket.
Or Bucky.
Wait, what do you want to protect?
Thing?
I like Thing Mag and if Mag's dead, I'll feel...
Yeah, no, no, sure.
I mean, I like Strange Mag.
Protect, yeah, yeah.
Should we...
Do you want... Should we ban Rocket or Namor then?
Woah.
That's you guys.
Because if you do a Punisher infinite, that's like... that's also like not fun to play against.
We only have one ban.
I leave it up to you.
Alright, okay.
Ban... Ban...
Okay, it's either Rocket or Namor.
Do you guys think we can deal with another Namor player?
Does he play Namor?
Namor is easy to play.
Like anybody can play Namor.
But Rocket we can get rid of the infinite.
So we just do Rocket then.
Ban Rocket?
Yeah.
Rocket makes Punisher and Bucky like not the best characters.
Because if they're banning Mag we don't have a shield.
Oh, I've... Oh, yeah.
Um, well you can play Cloaker too.
Whichever one you feel more comfortable with.
If you feel more comfortable with Cloaker we can deal with it.
Yeah.
Don't tell other teams, but like this guy is lowkey like a Widow one trick.
Yo, chill.
That's what my friend told me.
Yo, chill!
I was like, I wonder who they're gonna get on our team to replace me next week.
And then my friend was like, Oh, they got this guy.
He's a Widow one trick.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's good.
Yo, get that LF Hella, bro!
Nah, Hella's just so much damage.
Lock the Mantis.
Get the Widow.
Get some headshots.
Wait, in soloQ I TP to their high ground here.
Is that like throw?
No, it's not.
It's still pretty okay.
I think it's better to save TP mostly.
Yeah, like usually, yeah, it's just like a back and forth.
Okay, we're going Widow.
We need a Mantis so...
I'll get August.
I think we need the team up.
That's what we need.
Get on Hawkeye.
Get the fuck off of there.
It's okay.
No matter what we at least still get a thousand dollars.
A thousand dollars!
And a video probably.
True.
A video?
Unless you go like 0-7.
I was gonna say 0-7.
I don't know.
Wait, what if he goes...
Alright, let's go point.
Come right side.
Careful.
I messed up my dash.
Yeah, I was gonna say careful.
They're behind.
He's behind.
I froze him.
I froze him behind.
He's one.
There you go.
We can push up with that.
I got it.
Don't worry.
Can't finish it.
I'm back.
Help Coney.
Find the Bucky!
His name is Robbie Dean!
I'm dying.
I'm healed.
Coney has to stay on point again.
Yeah, I'm staying on.
Have to reload.
Oh my god, I got...
Bucky, very low.
Oh, low.
Yeah, he's in that thing.
Alright, let's group up here.
Coming back.
I got you.
That looks annoying.
Oh.
Back up if you can.
Yeah, just back up.
Reset fully.
Yep, I got it.
Alright.
We gotta wait for...
Wait for sure for...
I'm back.
Alright, let's go.
Oh wait, you're fucking Bucky.
I don't know why.
Flankers are not good.
I'm locked in.
Wide among us.
You wanna do cloak first?
Yeah, cloak first.
I only do...
I'm like one.
I froze, huh?
Got a bunch.
Yeah, it's in their ult, though.
Yeah, it's in their ult.
You're right.
I'm ulting.
I have to ult this.
Oh, hello.
Oh wait, look, look, Bucky!
Oh no!
Goodbye, Sherwood!
No, I'm good.
They have strange ult.
Careful of strange ult.
I missed the froze.
No.
I think at this point, we have to go triple support.
Yeah, we could.
Or Hulk.
I don't think we should play Hulk.
But if we do triple support, we can't run the thing.
Okay.
I'll just go to mag.
Not yet, not yet.
We're poiling.
I'm stuck behind, though.
You have to jump on.
No, no, we have time.
It's alright.
High ground.
He's blocking us.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Can we shoot this guy?
There's a Hulk behind us.
I need heals if you can.
Hulk is still weak.
It's fine, we got it.
We're fine, we're fine.
Thank you.
I'm grabbing the low key.
Where the fuck are they?
Yeah.
You're not going to fall for that, Taxi.
We can push up a bit, no?
Yeah, we can.
They have...
Do you want to cloak first?
Always cloak first.
I'm always going to try and get the strange doll if I can.
Just Luna, relax.
Right here, right here.
They're going to have...
Yeah, they do, they do.
So we try and cloak that.
Oh no.
I'm dead.
Yeah, we have to use that.
I'm getting Hulk-culted.
Oh, what's happening?
Hulk on?
Oh, I got fucking pushed out of it.
Woah, woah, woah.
I got pushed out of it, yo.
We might have to run triple support, I think.
Yeah, it was a big ult, but...
This is untouchable.
Next point.
Okay, wait, who do you want solo tank?
We need either... we need mag.
Solo tank is always mag.
Oh, mag's bad?
Oh shit, alright, then we can just run strange.
That's all we could do.
Or triple support, or do...
Well, if you want a strange, Coney, I can add him.
Um, okay, I can try it.
Strange isn't great.
I mean, I'm okay with it, but if we need to run a triple support, and you gotta go add him, that's fine.
I'll go it.
It's just not as good as mag, so...
Your guy's called, though.
I think we... the thing is, like, uh...
When, uh...
When we have strange, you just get...
Either you play a little passive on strange, because you get deleted so fast.
Because you're frontlining way too hard.
That's fine, I'll hold it back.
Yeah, and it, um...
Because, like, Lulu and I can't heal the strange player.
Since you get deleted way too fast for us.
I'm just gonna play... I'm gonna put the orb on surefire.
We might switch to Thor.
We'll see.
Or we nunge the three.
Three's always works.
Loki's top left.
Real Loki.
It's fine.
I can ult this if you want.
I'm ulting.
I'm just blocking it.
I'm blocking it.
Walk forward.
There's a hell of a minus.
I forced ult.
I'm still bonded.
Nice.
Oh, wow.
We died to that.
That Agamotto...
Oh, yeah.
No, it's Agamotto, yeah.
Probably just gonna rip my ult next fight.
Yeah, I'm getting mine, too.
I portal.
Yeah.
We could try it.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna portal high ground.
One second.
Oh, I was gonna say.
Alright, going real high on this one.
Okay.
Nice kill.
Loki down.
They're all low up here.
What the hell?
You can drop down while they're down at support.
Alright, I'm dropping down.
Go.
I'm gonna ult Loki here.
Got it.
Nice.
Again.
Hulk can die.
Get the...
Hulk?
Anybody?
No, we have to try and get a reset for it.
Oh, hello one.
Hello one.
Nice.
Again.
I'm gonna reposition here so I can have ult.
Yeah, they're gonna have Hulk ult and also...
A squirrel here.
Loki on the right.
He's looking for it to dive at support.
He's diving at support.
Why don't you guys stay on point?
I'm staying on the point.
My ult's down.
Oh, I'm getting smashed.
Yes, you are.
I can't rez here.
There's a strange pushing behind.
Oh, you can rez?
That's unfortunate.
This map's hard.
They fucking can walk into us.
Yeah.
I can rez.
No, no rez.
Don't rez.
We can't.
Don't waste it.
Just come back.
I have eye up.
Let's just wait for everybody.
I have ult for the strange ult.
Yeah, let's come before we ult because if you ult and I soulbond, we're just wasting one.
Just let me know before.
It's better if you save the soulbond for your defensive.
Are you ready to go?
I'm pushing up.
Yeah, I'm ready.
There's a Hulk behind us.
It's fine.
I'm gonna jump off the ult backline.
Hulk's on me in the back.
They're gonna... Adam, you have to hide.
You have to hide.
He's got a strange ult.
I can't keep you up.
That's good.
Nice.
Okay.
I just tried to get the backline.
Here we go.
I have to touch point.
I'm gonna die first then.
I got a support.
Nice.
Hulk low.
Hulk's one.
Oh, we're just off.
I don't know.
Warm up.
Are you using finer rolls or the team comp?
I mean like the easiest one.
The best comp is 3-3.
Wait, 3-3?
3-3 goats, 3 tanks, 3 supports because that's what pro play is playing right now.
And it's the easiest comp to play.
I mean, I'm done.
Unless like we could... I don't know.
Shurpa, what do you think?
At this point, it just has to be everyone playing in their most comfortable way.
Yeah, I think.
I was thinking that.
Everyone just plays whatever they're comfortable with.
Shit.
Just play your best character.
Block the Mantis Widow, fuck it.
Yeah, let's just do it.
I'll do Mantis Widow.
And we need to do triple support though.
We're doing Mantis Widow.
But someone has to go Luna.
Someone has to go Luna or we ban Luna so we have main heals.
I can do Luna.
Yeah, we need Luna and then...
And then either Adam or Cloak or Sue.
I think... Yeah, I'm down.
I can say... Any time... Okay, we need to... The only thing I need help with is calm what we're looking at.
Because sometimes I notice when Hulk's on you guys, I'm trying to fight their other tank and then you guys aren't looking at me and I'm not looking at you.
So we're just doing different shit and then nothing does.
So I need to... I mean, that's probably on me but let's just try.
Yeah, we can calm it louder because usually I freeze the Hulk or I just say Hulk's frozen or Hulk's down.
I think I should just turn around and help you guys there because there's...
If you guys are ever distracted...
You don't turn around.
If you're playing... Wait, who's talking?
Sorry.
I'm strange.
You don't turn around.
You just back up because the other tank... You're the main frontline tank and you're just supposed to back up but the other tank is supposed to turn around.
Or one of the DPS turns around because we can't lose our frontline.
Yeah, and I got you.
Who's our next round?
Our next round is... Are we making it?
Oh, we keep the lobby.
We're just gonna keep stealing the lobby.
I cannot be bothered.
Um... Timmy has not added me yet.
Oh, I meant the view career.
Let me see.
Who's on Timmy's team?
Maybe I have someone on Timmy's team.
I like how they say Timmy's team but they're captains more.
Wait, Kony, you left.
Kony, we're stealing the lobby.
We have the same lobby.
We're just gonna keep using the lobby.
Yeah, my bad.
Yeah, honestly, I think we need... No, we shit on these guys.
We just need better focus.
If we just look at the same thing, we win.
GG.
Dude, we're unsolvable.
That's kind of how I feel.
I consistently have people one hit, two hit, whatever.
And I don't feel like I'm too deep in but they're not dying.
I feel like we're just not looking at the same stuff.
True.
Well, sometimes not everyone can hit the same target because there's different things going on.
Also true.
Alright, so Trifor and I are just gonna run Widow, Mantis.
Where are you guys gonna run?
At best, we think just play what you're most comfortable with.
I'm gonna be on Widow.
Yeah, aren't you gonna be on Widow?
You can play Widow.
I play on Widow.
I don't give a fuck.
Just by the way, I looked at...
Most likely, Trifor and I are just gonna run flank and stuff so you guys just head up the front line so we won't see what's going on.
Okay, sure.
Are we all ready?
Yeah.
Guys, at least we get $1,000.
Wait a minute, this may not work against this team.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, actually this team is tryhard as fuck.
It may not work against this team.
You're right.
I just noticed all the ranks.
We're against the titans right now.
Who the fuck is LeBron James?
Is that the real LeBron?
Yeah, that's the real LeBron James.
LeBron, you play Rivals?
Alright.
I love you.
What if I just go Mr. Fantastic?
You're gonna get shredded so fucking hard.
I know the flank Mr. Fantastic.
I would love to see it.
Alright, I'll go Mr. Fantastic.
I'm done.
The Pop-Tart man.
Wait, this is unironically my best map.
Really?
I think my winner is like 70%.
I don't know why.
Yeah, we're gonna make it 50% tonight.
We're gonna make it 60%.
Bring that shit down.
Alright,
we'll just... unless we want to wait for Toast to ping.
Does he actually ping us?
I was not paying attention.
I just kept going.
The second one, he said, once you're ready, feel free to go log in too.
Yeah, once we're ready.
Oh, we were ready in like ban phase.
Alright, nice.
I'm going in.
He said, once you're ready.
I was like, alright, I'm definitely ready.
We don't really play Loki, right?
I play Loki, but I can do Loki.
Because I know more as a Loki enthusiast.
Well, yeah, then we'll just ban Loki then.
Because he's like the most annoying support.
You're captain, by the way.
Uh, Lulu.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, just ban... I mean, we can ban Loki.
Just fuck more.
Fuck him, I guess.
Aw, what?
Did they hear us wanting to play Mantis Widow?
Yeah, they're watching the stream.
What the fuck?
Wait, what the heck?
No, it's because... it's because...
Hune more on the enemy team.
Whenever I six stack them, we just go Mantis Widow.
We are doing Loki, right?
Yeah, Loki.
That was crazy.
All good.
Two Widow players.
Wait, who are we protecting?
Honestly, like, there's nothing...
We just keep doing the thing because we don't really have a thing that we need to protect.
That's fine.
Like, all of us have characters that we want to play.
Yeah.
We could also keep Mag, because both our tanks can Mag.
That's true.
I don't think they are going to ban Mag, though.
I don't have a thing.
I like thing.
Um...
The thing.
We could ban Namor here.
Just because I don't want to play against Namor.
You know what?
Let's do that.
Let's have a Namor free game.
Every game has a fucking ugly ass hello, bro.
Yo, chill.
Sorry.
Yo.
Just fucking playing aim labs on my fucking head.
Yeah, I totally didn't play hello last few games.
All good.
Oh, God.
What are you going to ban, Mr. Fantastic?
Oh, Luna.
Okay.
Um...
Don't ban Namor.
It doesn't matter.
If they ban Luna, we can still have...
Namor is, like, obsolete.
I mean, we could just ban...
They might go Rocket Punisher.
Then we ban Rocket.
Maybe.
Okay, ban Rocket.
Alright.
Uh...
I mean...
Yeah, I can go still here.
Ooh.
You believe in your...
Do you believe in your Starlord surefire?
Uh...
If I get Megabubbles mid-game?
Eh, yeah.
You can try that.
Whenever he E's, you bubble him.
Boom.
Sir, yes, sir.
We could just comment.
They might run Spidey combo.
I don't think...
I don't...
I don't think duo...
I feel like if we're at it, we'll watch E for E support.
Oh, this is such a widow map.
That's true.
Alright, I'll just...
I'll just E then.
I think, like...
It works if, like...
We can scrim...
If we scrim with it, but...
Yeah, I thought this was...
Fucking Hall of Jala.
We had, like, the wrong maps locked in.
Is this what this is called?
I thought it was the other Panther map.
No, it's this one.
Yeah, that threw me too.
I thought the Hall was, like, the domination map.
Yeah.
Okay, that's the one I'm...
We can crack that.
They didn't say anything, so I don't know if I picked...
Did I pick the wrong map?
I don't...
I really...
I don't think they care.
Oh, that's fine.
This is a content creator.
It's alright.
They got a magic.
They have a thing.
Thing.
I didn't...
Yeah, they're gonna dive by the looks of it.
They're gonna dive?
Okay, I'll try to push the point.
Hey, Thomasline's on you.
I'll try to save bubble.
Magic going high ground.
I know.
I think they're all up there.
They're all going high.
All up there.
All high.
Uh, thing is...
They're going back.
They're going backline.
They're going back all the way back.
All the way back.
They're gonna flank us.
Yeah.
I'm out of HP.
I'm all the way around.
Cool.
They have no mag bubble.
Nice.
One.
We can push up with this one.
I pushed.
Hold him back.
I'm holding.
Surround.
He can't get up there.
That's fine.
Wait, someone's down.
Got it.
Hold on.
Adam fell.
Chasing.
Okay, nice.
Sagger him if needed.
Good shit.
They're all down.
Yay!
We can get up.
I've never seen somebody go all the way around on that.
That was crazy.
Literally, you can ult face.
I have a Bucky now.
I don't know if they always had it.
Nah.
He was on Najik.
Oh, yeah.
They're hooks.
They're going right again, I think.
No, they're main.
They're main.
The thing is up top.
Don't die, man.
Oh, wow.
I'm dying.
Yeah, we're trying our best to heal you.
You guys were taking too much damage.
No, I...
Jesus.
Forgot that I can't shift if you shift.
You guys...
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't think we can contest it.
Oh, no, I'm fucked up.
I already...
I got it, I got it.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
I can't push that guy away.
He's hooking, careful.
Okay, reset, reset.
Let's make sure we don't overlap support ults.
Oh, no.
Lose first, lose first.
We can use this to...
Use it to go in.
Not yet, not yet, though.
Okay, are we ready?
No, not yet, not yet, not yet, not yet.
We don't have everybody.
Someone's above us.
Yeah, it's the thing.
Funky's up there.
Yeah.
We can...
Maybe think flank too.
I got spawn camp.
Okay, I think we have to use it to engage at this corner.
Just because, like...
We can wait for them.
There's a hellion high ground.
Come on, I have to.
I don't have to do it now.
That's fine.
That's a good ult, that's a good ult.
What?
I was out of it?
Alright, I'm gonna ult backline.
I'm gonna hold it, though.
Waiting.
I'm coming back.
Okay, well...
We'll probably be fine.
Hellion's on this corner.
Oh, I got shiny.
I'm gonna use it just to stall.
I pulled him in.
I pulled people in.
Oh, I'm dead.
Bucky can die in the back.
Bucky is one.
We got Bucky.
Hold on.
I don't have...
Okay, I'm just trying to keep you alive.
Okay, okay.
Coney, careful.
Yep, yep.
Wait, look ping, look ping.
They rezzed.
Yeah.
Jesus.
We're trying to keep you guys alive here.
We have to touch, we have to touch.
Yeah, someone touch, someone touch.
I got one.
Just keep, just keep...
I'll try.
Wait, kill the Bucky.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
What the fuck is he doing?
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
There's a HelloHyga.
HelloHyga is still here.
HelloHyga is still.
Which... oh, top left.
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no.
Right when I hit my Q.
There's an Adam2 behind us too.
Adam, yeah, I can't.
You guys have...
I'm just trying to stay on point.
You have no supports, you have no supports.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm just gonna...
back here.
Yeah, they had people that were really out of position there.
Like, I killed two just because they walked up.
Just calm where, like, Hella was top left.
Calm like where you see her.
Yeah, I pinged her.
I was like, Hella up top.
Stay left for me though.
Because I thought it was right high ground.
That's where I see Hella's usually.
It's a weird spot.
Maybe this guy's just too high ELO for my brain.
No, he's a COD player.
He's a COD player.
Oh, too low ELO for my brain.
Didn't he win, like, championships though?
Okay, too high ELO.
Hella's top left.
Use ult, use ult, use ult.
I don't have my ult yet.
I'm shielding.
I got it.
Okay, nice.
Good shield.
Oh my god.
We're up one.
We can push up.
Yeah, push up.
Okay, we stopped it, we stopped it.
This guy's one.
Adam, Adam, Adam, Adam.
Push it up, push it up, push it up.
Just push up, push up, push up.
I pulled him back, I pulled him back.
Thank you.
I got you.
No, we can keep pushing.
Dude, fuck these guys.
They're like three alive.
We can't push anymore, we can't push anymore, we can't push anymore.
That's their spawn.
Wait, kill this thing, kill this thing.
Alright, good.
Let's push it back.
Because like, two of them are dead, plus they're like...
Yeah, but respawn was coming in.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But we gotta fuck with their mental.
I can bubble you if you're stuck.
You can jump to me, I think.
Okay.
He's gonna, uh, burn it if we can.
At best I can give a shield, but I'm just gonna back up.
I'm in this hallway.
It's burned, it's burned.
I couldn't heal you in time.
Oh, I got hooked.
We can't do anything, there's a health on us.
Yeah, I'm dead.
I tried to jump-save, but...
If we reset here, we have time.
I think I can jump if time I can.
No, what?
He randomly shot that.
That's crazy.
That was a good play by him.
Have ults up once we're all here.
Yeah.
Alright, I'm dashing in.
Just gonna stay on point.
Bucky's on the right.
Hella one, hella one!
Sniping this guy!
Wait, he died.
I was behind the walls.
I have my ult.
I'm about to use it.
Weird.
You have shield, you have shield on him!
You have shield, shield, shield, shield!
I got it, I got it.
Kill the mag, kill the mag!
I pulled mag, I pulled mag, I pulled mag!
Oh, he got those.
I don't know where he was.
Okay, good warm-up, we win now.
We warm up until we win, is that it?
It's T-sided, it's T-sided.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
I'm just gonna run at him.
I will bring peace to this universe, no matter the cost.
Let me know...
Let me know, like...
A bit before the fight, you're gonna cloak ult?
I'll save bubble.
Okay.
I don't know, I actually don't know what...
Matches are rough, guys.
Should've done that.
Matches are...
I got killed in both my ults, all good.
Matches are rough, guys.
But it's okay.
At least...
Last night, I gained 100 points and I'm on the leaderboard.
That's all that matters to me.
I'm trying, I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best.
It's okay, everybody...
The price difference is...
I believe like...
I think it's like $1,000?
I think, I don't know.
Even last place gets $1,000.
And I think first place gets $1,700.
So I'm okay with that.
Yeah, we got it.
I'll swap off if it doesn't work.
I think...
Jake, maybe go Bucky if...
Psylocke doesn't work.
Yeah, I could go Bucky.
Or like...
Punisher.
Yeah.
There's a Hella behind Flanky.
I have to use both snaps.
Actually, I'm gonna go high ground.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hard left, hard left.
Come on.
They're on high ground.
No, they're on top right.
Just fight here, just fight here.
Ken can't move, Ken can't move.
Nice, nice.
We got pick.
I'm just gonna...
I'm soulbonding us and we go for it.
Go for it, I soulbonded us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm walking, I'm walking.
Look, Mag.
Or Thing... or Wanda, actually.
Yeah, Wanda, Wanda.
Nice.
Thing, Thing, Thing, Thing.
Thing one, Thing low.
Thing, focus Thing.
Focus Thing again.
Yeah.
Focus Thing.
Don't... Thing is 1 HP.
Yeah.
Now you can get the high ground if you want to.
Alright, good claim.
Yay.
You're killing them before I can bust.
Oh, I'm surprised he's gonna stay at Scarlet.
The Cosmos heal.
I have Res soon.
I got Cloak ult.
I'm just gonna...
We don't have any ults because we engaged so fast, so...
Jesus.
I'm gonna go up near Wanda.
That's you.
I'm gonna go up here and look for flank if...
Careful, careful.
You're by yourself, Strange.
Yeah, yeah.
Thing is, like, not with you.
Yeah, I'm gonna go around and go to...
and flank if I can get time.
I am strengthened for battle.
Alright.
I have Res.
Nevermind, I'm coming up front.
Yeah, that's a good ult.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
I'm just gonna Res.
I'm gonna Agumon off this.
I have...
I'm just gonna save.
Save my Res.
I'm gonna wait.
Blocked it.
Nice.
Thing's on me in the back.
I'm getting punched.
See ya.
Okay, I'm Resing this then.
You should be fine.
Yep.
I'm solo botting.
You can go up with it.
I'm staying on point.
Back up, back up again, back up again.
That's a...
Scarlet ult.
That's huge, that's huge, that's a huge ult.
I need heals though.
I'm gonna swap out Adam now.
I think...
I'm gonna ult and swap.
That's fine.
Tripper got two.
Wait, they're only one healer right now, Fee.
Oh, we're a bit saggy.
No, we're saggy.
Yeah, it's saggy.
It's fine.
Um, they have...
They used Herald, they used...
Alright, I'm gonna go inside...
I'm gonna go inside this building and get backline with ult.
Just gonna go up here.
See if I can get it.
Just waiting for space.
Alright, going backline.
I pulled Mag back.
I can block his healing.
Mag is one.
Oh, unlucky.
There's no healing.
Yeah.
I got him.
Oh, unlucky.
Think, think, think, think, think.
Burn, burn Hela, burn.
We had to burn Hela.
One healer.
We had to burn Hela there.
That's okay.
Hey, Timmy, big fan.
Kill him.
He's not pushing.
Careful, you're by yourself, Strange.
Yeah, I'm okay.
You only have Mia's healing.
I'm playing two, like, beta.
I gotta walk into these guys.
Type shit.
Well, there was only three of us, so...
Off-angle DPSes.
There's a...
Hela to the left, Hela to the left.
I pinged it.
I have my ult, too.
I'm gonna get purple here.
I don't have a choice.
I'm gonna pull down.
No!
I got, I got...
Oh, look, think, think.
I think we reset.
No, reset.
Oh, I got it.
I'm just gonna die here.
I have an Agamotto.
I thought you wouldn't see me again.
Can't wait to get pulled by Invisible Woman.
They have Mag...
They have Mag ult.
Here.
Okay.
I have my...
Lulu, you go first.
Yes.
Okay.
Do you want me to engage with mine?
Um, we can use for engagement.
They don't...
They have one aggressive ult here.
Hooking, hooking.
Did you have bubble for her?
Chill, then got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
You hope they both push me?
I, uh...
Pulled.
We're back.
Big bust.
Oh, wow.
Huge.
Big bust.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Got...
Nice.
Okay.
Think, think, think.
Someone's still above us.
Who's above us?
Bucky, Bucky's behind.
Above and behind.
I can't chase him.
I'm stuck in this room.
Oh, he has...
He has this again.
But he has Mantis ult, though.
Mantis, Bucky.
I want them to kill me.
Hey, guys.
Uh-oh.
Goodbye, Surefour.
Oh, you didn't get the reset.
I can portal.
Actually, we probably should just walk.
So I can portal last fight if we need to.
You'll have to...
Alright, we'll have to die first, then.
That's up to you.
We don't have time for a portal, but...
Yeah, I think we're off.
I'm gonna tank some damage.
We can get healer ult charge.
See me?
Oh!
Oh, everyone's low.
I have ult for this charge.
Yeah, I'm just waiting.
Burn, burn that burn.
Burn however you can.
Burn her, burn her, burn.
She's barely one.
She's down.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna walk up.
Running in with ult.
One second.
Yeah, I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
Come on, Mantis.
Nice.
Mantis, Mantis.
That's huge, that's huge, that's huge.
Help her, help her, help her.
I'll pop myself up.
Oh, I...
Oh, I'm dying.
That thing is on me.
There is a...
We have a cloak on point.
It's gonna be gone.
It's gone now.
Try to stall until invis ult.
I'm one, I'm one.
I'm coming back.
Bye, everybody.
I'll see you all die in front of me.
Damn.
Hey, good warm-up, actually.
Good warm-up, good warm-up.
Hello, good warm-up, guys.
GG.
Hey, whoever that Magneto is, he only ulted my shield like five times.
Oh, he's Eternity.
Okay, well...
It wasn't bad, I was just...
I don't know.
I feel like we should have capped.
I guess, I think their Hela killed like eight at one point.
We didn't burn Hela the first time, so like...
We just let her stay up in the air.
The old game.
It's worse though.
It's just like little things, honestly.
It's alright.
Yeah.
Okay, now we can run Mantis.
Wait, who are we playing against?
Oh, wait, no.
Fuck, it's Nekros.
No, actually, Nekros is just Andrew and Nekros.
And we just banned Venom Spider because they've been fucking running that the entire time in rank.
It's terrible.
Spider-Man, one trick.
Yeah, I had to deal with that in rank last week.
So, it was not fun.
We just banned Venom Spider because Andrew is like the number one Venom right now in...
in EU.
We can only ban one.
They're gonna save one.
Oh, it's true.
We just banned Venom.
Andrew only plays Venom.
From all the times I've gotten him.
I mean, he played Mag and Strange, but his Venom is actually so fucking annoying.
Yeah.
I mean, like...
I hate Venom.
Nekros Spider-Man is also annoying, but like, I'd rather just not deal with a Venom.
Oh, really?
I was thinking...
Oh, yeah, I'm done.
Fuck it.
No, I had to play against that for last week, and I'd rather deal with Nekros Spider-Man than Andrew's Venom.
Because Venom has too much HP.
The problem with dealing with Spider-Man though is that like, we're gonna get clip farmed.
That's fine, I already got clip farmed.
He already clip farmed me, I'm okay with that.
Wait, what?
You played against the Spider-Man, right?
Yeah, no, I played against him.
Did you kill him on Widow or no?
He played Panther, but...
Well, I think... I had a few kills on him for sure.
But, it wasn't like anything... I don't know.
It wasn't like notable or anything.
Do you want me to add him against dive or should I say tank?
I don't care.
I am a listener.
Should we just run Strange Mag and see if that works?
Are you okay with running Strange Mag?
Yeah, that's good with me.
That's true, he did say he couldn't kill my Widow.
Let's just run Strange Mag.
Just play around with comps.
And see what works.
Necros is still in the game though, so I can't invite him.
That means we have to wait.
Yeah, no.
No.
No tears, only dreams.
Should we still try Mantis Widow against Necros?
I'm down to try anything.
I'll even lock the Mr. Fantastic.
I'll play anything.
I'm trying my best.
Guys, I'm trying my best.
I don't know if my comps are bad or not.
I don't know.
I don't know if my comps are not good enough or something.
I feel like I'm the only one talking.
I feel like I'm the only one talking right now.
So I'm just like, I don't know.
I'm just like, I'm trying.
I'm trying my best to support him.
Yeah.
The vibes aren't peak.
I don't know what to do.
Everyone's just sad that they're losing and I'm like, I'm trying.
And also, we did have like a last minute substitute too.
Because Wig dropped out.
I have returned.
So like we did have like a last minute substitute and everything too.
I'm going to watch a motivational speech.
We're going to fucking glorp on these guys.
Let me get Tony Hype the fuck up.
David Goggins.
I'm not a motivational speaker, guys.
Do you have a good motivational speech?
No, I just watch like the cringe compilation.
I thought all of this was doom posting.
Stay hard!
I don't do this because I want to do this.
He's kind of doom posting.
Isn't he the guy that is in all the like sad boy movies?
It's okay, just like last time.
Wait, no, who are you thinking of?
Just like last time, I'll feel better by playing quick play.
Is it Ryan Gosling?
Why is it David Goggins?
Oh.
Don't worry about it, I'm cooked.
Oh my god, bro.
Okay, this Astron guy was like in my chat, like in the waiting room, capping out my waiting room.
And was like, I better not see you in Gomez and Rink, you're going to regret it.
Who the fuck are you?
We have a high win percent rate, so I'm pretty sure we won again.
He starts his fucking short, like running.
A guy asked me, what do you want?
Like, their date night is just like his girlfriend's husband's wife driving the car behind him.
It could have been like someone that Gomez blames, honestly, and then he's like taking it out on me.
Because I don't even talk in game at all, other than comming.
But Gomez blames people, so like, it could be him taking it out on me because he's too scared to like, to like say anything to Gomez.
That's like all I can think about.
You think you can do that?
Who the fuck is... oh wait, I think it's because like, I made it open to all.
Okay, invitational only.
Yeah, so, because like, I don't say anything in chat.
The most I did was like, the most I did was, could you swap off, please?
And that's all I say.
I also don't have you added.
Add Glorpfan5000.
It's like the dog that only barks.
Oh wait, he's here.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, it's random.
No, people take, I mean, I took rank very seriously because I was like, I just want to be on the leaderboards.
Because like, if anything bad happens in this tournament, at least I can be happy about like, my individual rank.
I was just like, thinking like, okay, if I get too sad, I can just think about how much I climbed last night.
And then that will make me at least a little happy.
That's why I was like, I don't want to at least get on the leaderboards for this tournament.
So like, I can be less sad.
Because I was like, it's a creative tournament.
Teams are obviously gonna be very RNG.
Alright guys, the good news is both teams in this current match that is about to happen is 0-3.
Holy shit, it's the comeback.
Okay, so it's basically...
We could get out of this loss streak by continuing theirs.
Or...
True!
That's gonna happen to us.
Alright, Kony, Kony motivate us.
You're always the hype man, Kony.
No!
Now?
Why is that my job?
Our hype man isn't even hype!
No, I'm scared.
If they're 0-3, I don't want to be 0-4 to the 0-3 team.
I'm scared now!
Okay, wait, no, no.
Pause.
You're telling me you used to be a Smash player?
Like a pro Smash player?
What happened to your ego?
Like, a decade and a half ago, maybe.
Okay, but...
You know what happened to my ego?
Did you used to be... Did you compete in Smash?
Yes or no?
You know what happened to my ego?
I kept... In the last few games, I've heard like, oh, Hella's high, Bucky's high, they're high ground, and I look up his thing, I'm like, I can't...
I can't...
This guy is literally telling me he's down three stocks, he's on his last stock, and he just jumps off the fucking map.
That's what he does.
He jumps off.
That's what I'm fucking hearing right now.
I actually do.
If I know we're not winning, but I know we're gonna win this.
Oh my god.
I'm sad now.
That was the saddest speech I've ever heard.
I'm literally not the loser.
This dude's anti-hype, bro.
Let me take your mental.
This is anti-type.
All good?
Wait, what's the map?
Oh, a spider... Wait, is this... Is Spider Islands the city or the doge?
This is Gibraltar.
What's the doge?
This is Gibraltar, first point.
A dojo.
I like that one.
Momentum is fragile.
Takes a lifetime to build, but only a moment of neglect to lose.
Think about that.
Are you watching the David Goggins video right now?
I'm reading a synopsis.
A synopsis?
You're watching or listening to it?
You're reading it?
Yo, chill.
That was off the dome.
How is that even motivational if you're reading it?
You know when you unroll a toilet paper, right?
If you roll it back, it's not going to be the same, okay?
And now we're unrolling it that far.
Yeah, why are you unrolling it?
Why are you rolling too much of it?
He's got a big-ass batch of fortune cookies he's reading from.
I like that.
That's very deep.
You guys have no idea how many times he's said this to me before.
He's just rolling out all his voice lines.
Chill.
Oh, he's doing his stim voices?
Yeah.
I have a thick of it on a soundboard.
I could DMC all your VODs right now.
Do it right now.
Yo, yo, chill.
I'd love to give that guy more money.
Do it.
Yeah.
He needs it.
Alright, I'm going to get demonetized on YouTube.
No, that was like two seconds.
Oh yeah, she's on YouTube.
You killed her.
You fucked me over.
You actually fucked me over.
Wow.
When my team captain spoke, I listened.
Of course, of course, of course you actually fucked me over.
Don't let DokiBird gaslight you.
It's women's month.
It's every month.
What an angle.
How much backpedaling is this guy going to do?
I know, right?
Stand your ground for once.
Doki, how much longer did you play that cheetah game?
The cheetah game?
After like an hour, I was like, I get it.
Yeah, like after you left, I played like two more and I was like, okay, I'm done now.
Yeah, I figured it was going to be like that.
It's like, I get it.
Okay.
I'm done.
Everybody can aim, but I get it now.
Keep in mind, if we lose, not only are we on four, but we lose to TTV in name.
Oh no.
My viewers.
They're all going to leave.
I like the small TTV, though.
That's kind of cool.
I fuck with it.
Oh my god, I didn't even notice the little TV.
The all caps is kind of cringe.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that's a meme.
Is that Andrew?
Is it RickyTV?
I was going to say, they only have two Eternity players.
But it still does mental damage to us.
To me, at least.
Get that mental up, bro.
I know.
Who are you eating for?
What if we level the playing fields and we play in Singapore servers?
What if I just put West Coast on and just fuck over Nicklaus and Andrew?
Nah, fuck the Europeans.
Yeah, fuck the Europeans.
That's what I'm saying.
Wait, if Ricky is not Andrew?
Who the fuck is Ricky?
It's fucked up, man!
Who's Ricky?
I thought they only had two Eternity players.
One above all.
Ricky is supposed to be Celestial!
Oh, I guess he ranked up.
I mean, Celestial and Eternity are next to each other.
Yo, why is there a Diamond in this lobby?
Yo!
I'm cooked!
Alright, let me know when I...
Okay, so did we decide we're banning Venom?
Wait, what rank did you tell him I was?
Venom?
No, Toast asked for Diamond 1 to GM.
Yeah, he was like, no Celestials.
I wasn't yet.
I don't know who Ricky is.
Who is Ricky, guys?
Is Twitch name actually just Ricky?
He's a real person?
I don't know.
That's fucked up!
Oh my god, he's...
Wait, he's not even... Oh no, he is real!
Who's real?
What did I miss?
I was like, oh, he's the Call of Duty player.
He's the COD player.
I was gonna say.
Alright, they are not ready yet, so I'm just gonna wait.
Why not?
I mean, we could start it now.
Wait, how the fuck is this team 0-3?
Yeah, I know.
I mean, they might just target that Andrew Necros, honestly.
They could have just done that.
At this point, like, they gotta go for content, so surely they give us a win.
Well, they want content as in they win.
Okay, so we have one drawback, Doki.
This map isn't good for Widow.
Oh, that's true.
This map's kinda ass.
When will we ever be able to play Widow, Mantis?
Next game.
The last... The next game.
Our Tuanta guy is like 50 hours Widow and like 1 hour everyone else.
Okay, yo, you don't have to like keep saying that.
No, that's not true.
That's not true.
Okay, we win this.
Am I banning Venom?
Yeah.
Or Spider.
Venom.
I don't want... I'd rather deal with a Spider-Man than a Venom.
Venom just has too much HP.
Okay.
They're ready.
Wait, they're going Dive?
They're going for Dive.
Let's do... We can still have Bucky.
We can protect Bucky because they might try to ban Bucky.
Sure.
So ban Venom here?
Yeah.
At least we have Bucky for...
At least we'll have Bucky to help with Dive.
Yeah, protect Bucky.
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
And then they're just gonna protect Spider-Man so Necro can at least have fun out of the two.
Bucky.
So who are we banning third?
Spider-Man.
Oh, protect Mag.
Yeah, I mean he plays... Yeah, I'd rather just ban Spider.
Well...
What?
He might play Black Panther.
Yes, I was thinking about that too.
I was thinking he'll play Black Panther.
It's up to you guys.
Would you rather fight against Spider-Man or Panther?
I don't care.
It's up to healers, yeah.
I hate Spider-Man but I'm a tank so who cares.
I'd rather fight against...
I don't care either way.
It's up to you guys.
I'm okay with either Spider or Panther.
Other healer?
Lulu, what do you think?
Jake?
Spider or Panther?
I would just say Spider-Man.
You wanna deal with Spider-Man or you wanna deal with Panther?
I'd rather deal with Panther.
Okay, just ban Spider.
If anything, we can just go Loki.
Ban Spider.
Got it.
I can... we could go Luna, Loki just to deal with Loki.
I'm gonna run over their backline.
Okay, I'll give you the orb.
Three tanks is fine.
Yeah, just run two tanks.
It's fine.
I'm done.
We have burst heal and main heal.
And if I ever die, my health can rest.
Yeah, we have the revive.
Wait, we have some crazy power ups.
Alright, I'm done.
Oh yeah, we do the triple hella thing.
That's crazy.
Alright, Surefour.
Do what you do in rank.
Not solo queue though, mentality.
I always have the solo queue mentality.
Alright, we're gonna have to deal with Black Panther.
Oh, they protected Mag.
I don't know why I thought he was bad.
Yeah, if our backline is fucked, I can... we could also go Magneto thing.
Like, I could Mag, you could thing.
No, it's just... yeah, we could.
But I want to try, like, not having a thing to see what it's like.
Or I can always add.
Oh, there you got Bucky.
Yeah, they have Raccoon, triple healer.
Oh, they have infinite.
Yeah, they have infinite.
Don't peek, don't peek.
Oh yeah, they have infinite.
Just play around the corner.
Hugging, hugging.
I got you.
I can't move?
What the heck?
Wait, I'm... fuck.
I'm stuck against the ridge of the roof?
Okay.
He's frozen, he's... oh, he was solo.
I can bust, yeah.
All good.
Our teammates are respawning.
Let me just... stabilize.
Okay, I have no shield.
Careful, careful.
Oh, that hook lasted that long?
We couldn't get to you there.
Yeah, that character does that.
In fact, I'm out here.
I'm running trip support, I'm going Hawkeye.
Um, we could run trip support too.
Just to counteract that.
I don't play support, but like, fuck it.
I mean, do you play Adam?
Adam is basically a DPS support.
I can Adam if... well, yeah, you can't.
No, no, we need two tanks here.
We can learn.
Uh, Bucky's looking over the top right.
Or you could go Bucky instead of trip support.
I'll go first, I'll go first, I'll go first.
Behind us, behind us.
Mantis behind us.
I got pulled.
Oh, okay.
Alright, you don't... I'll shield it.
Yeah, shield, yeah, shield.
Nice, okay.
Yeah, I'm shielding.
Got it.
You don't... yeah.
Do you play Bucky?
Or no?
Or is Hella your most comfortable pick?
Uh, I mean, at this point, I could play anything.
But, I mean, Bucky's pretty simple.
I can play Bucky.
Oh, I'm trying, I can't see you yet.
Nah, I'm just dead.
I'm slow to wake up.
I didn't expect to be that far up.
We have only one... we have only one, uh...
We have like... oh, nice, nice.
Just push up if you can.
We have only one Contest here.
Oh, I'm not Agumoto-ing this, actually.
Thank you.
We're on point.
Yeah, Agumoto after this.
Copy me, copy me, copy me, copy me.
He's getting fucking melted.
I'm gonna have to Agumoto this.
I see you, I see you, I see you, I see you.
Doesn't matter.
We still have Mag all here.
I slept, I slept.
I'm trying to help you.
Nice.
No more ults, no more ults.
Loki's behind us.
I froze him.
Did he drop his shield?
I think it broke.
Yeah.
Okay, if, uh...
If the Bucky is too much for his again, we swap off Loki, because then it just gives him too much resets.
Yeah.
Uh, they're gonna have Mag ult too.
I have ult here.
Okay.
Hugging, hugging.
Oh, Coney.
I'm trying to keep you up, Coney.
Do you have bubble?
Do you have...
I have no shield.
Stay in the ammo, stay in the ammo.
We might need to swap off Loki just because of the Bucky, then.
Because he gets too many resets for that.
I'm back in the fight.
Press G.
Coney, Coney, back up in the spawn and G.
Might be a good time to stop them.
I feel like I'm being watched.
Uh...
They used both DPS ults.
I gave...
That's fine, I'm okay, I'm okay.
He hooked a strange.
I'm gonna die.
Another hook.
Got it.
Nice.
Hey, walk him down, walk him down.
Uh, Maglo, Maglo.
Punisher half.
I can't help you there.
I'm good.
Careful of hooks.
Nekroz is looking for hooks.
Careful, we can't see you.
Okay, only good player down.
That was crazy.
He's popping off, though.
They should have...
They have their DPS ults here, or like at least Punisher ult.
You can look for Agumoto here.
Yeah, try and get one of the support ults out of the way.
Nice, nice.
Mantis behind us.
Oh, I got pushed out.
I got you.
NT, NT.
Aisle first, aisle first.
Bring shield, Mag.
Okay.
Aisle first, aisle first.
Yeah, yeah, shield.
Use your shield, use your shield.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
We are undefeatable.
3, 2, 1.
Backing out.
Nekroz is on me.
Nekroz is on...
That's good.
You guys are even.
Oh, now you're down one.
Nice, you're even again.
Trevor, if you look at me.
I'm coming back.
No!
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna need help.
I'm trying to help you.
Got you.
Thank you.
I froze Mag.
I froze Mag behind you.
Mag is right behind you.
I don't have...
Can I be on our left?
Yeah, I don't have anything for it.
I got Mantis.
I couldn't.
I was way too...
We have to reset.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
You're down one, though.
You're down two.
No tanks.
You have no tanks.
So, be careful.
We can focus...
Their Bucky walks up a lot.
Like, we can focus him when he does that.
I don't have ult here.
Turret's one.
I'm low, though.
Can you see me?
I'm backing up.
Use it the moment you get it.
Honking it.
Almost have Agamotto.
Still use it?
No, no, no.
Don't use it.
We're fine.
He's hooking.
He's still hooking.
He's stabilized.
They're gonna punish ult here.
Fucking turret on the left there.
That lasted.
Care hook.
All right.
Blocked it.
Use it here.
I'm trying.
You have shield.
Shield her.
I almost got in there.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
This is last fight.
Nice.
Damage boosting.
One of us is dying, Nekros.
Mag, mag, mag, mag, mag.
They're portaling.
It's fine, it's fine.
They can touch.
Come here, Rekku.
Rekku's low.
There's a bubble down.
I couldn't.
I couldn't get in there.
What?
Oh, I'm dead as fuck.
I don't know if we could contest this.
Is that touchable?
No, it's not.
No, no, no.
I mean, honestly, good ult on that.
Dude, winnable.
Actually winnable.
We win this.
Yeah, sorry.
I should have said keep the mag bubble.
It's very close to ult that.
I had it in one.
Yeah, that was unlucky.
It was just about to come up.
It's alright.
It's winnable.
We can cap this, I think.
Same shit.
I'll keep the snowflake on you for sure for it.
And then I'll swap it to tank and let you know.
Aight.
How's the Bucky doing, by the way?
Oh yeah, um...
Are you comfortable with it or do you want to go something else?
Uh, I mean, I'm definitely learning Lmao, but...
Oh, then just snipe.
Just play snipe for now.
Or do we not need one?
I mean, I could just play hello.
You can play hello on this attack.
Yeah, just play whatever you want.
Play hello on the attack.
Kony, let me know when you're ulting so I can damage boost it.
Sure.
Turret's top right.
Careful.
I'm LOSing.
I'm shooting turret.
Turret down.
Infinite Amp real careful.
Yeah, don't peek that.
Don't peek that.
Wait until the Infinite's gone.
Somebody up here.
The Nectar's on, uh, they're on Psylocke.
They don't have a hook.
Focus on Tink.
Focus Tink.
Oh, he's one.
He's one.
Nice, nice, nice.
They're gonna have, uh, they're gonna have...
Psylocke on us in the back.
Psylocke in the back.
Yeah, I'm trying to help you.
There's still Psylocke behind us.
Psylocke's still behind us.
I'm asleep.
I'm dying.
Uh oh.
You're behind them.
Are you gonna live?
No, I'm not gonna live, but I'm trying to get one while I'm going down.
Portal out.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
That's huge.
I got one.
They're on Panther, by the way.
Big kill.
I'm walking him down.
I'm not stopping till he dies or I die.
No, I'm kidding, but...
I'll push up then.
We're on Panther, but I froze him.
I froze him.
I'm going back.
Psylocke didn't last very long.
Oh, okay.
I'm ulting.
Pushing up.
What is that?
Three, two, one.
You want me to ult in, too?
No, keep as a defense.
We need to keep as a defense.
I got you.
I got slapped.
No, you got slapped the moment the Panther died.
That was crazy.
I tried to save you, too.
Okay, I'm going to go low-key because of this Panther.
Yeah, good call.
I got Moto.
I'm just going to get fucking pushed, though.
Try to see if they use it.
Turret.
Panther on us.
I'm inmo.
Inmo's gone.
I'm trying to keep you up, though.
Nice, nice.
Panther's still behind us, by the way.
I'm trying to do my best to keep you guys up.
Nice kill.
No, I was right behind.
It hit the shield, but it...
Yeah, it was just that splash damage.
Oh, I can't play Adam because I don't have enough heals for Adam.
I can let Coney solo tank.
Come on.
I mean, we could try.
It's all about trying now.
We're all about trying whatever we want.
Nah, I'm fine.
I'm a strange man.
I'm ulting this, then.
Behind us, behind us.
He's low.
You're a slippery motherfucker, that guy.
They're behind us, top right.
At best, I have immo for him, but like, that's all I can...
Winnable.
Still winnable!
You have to ult, you can ult.
Rookie, rookie.
There's the Panther.
Panther's still on point.
Panther is still alive.
Jeez.
I don't have immo.
NT.
Warm up.
Nice try, nice try, nice try.
Nice try.
Nice try, nice try.
Still warm up.
It's alright, we're just trying to let people play what they're comfortable with in the end.
I think, like, only Shurifor and I are the flexers that can play whatever support or DPS is needed of us.
Yeah, it's just...
Should've unleashed the Widow.
Yeah, I don't know.
Uh...
I'm just trying to just play whatever they're comfortable with.
That's why I was like, I'll just play Lil' T.
Alright.
Alright, cool.
Who's our next matchup we're playing against?
Playing against Sleepy's team.
Um, we have...
I'm gonna play some ranked after this game.
Just to, I guess, feel a little bit better.
Uh, we have three more rounds left.
Wait,
so why is your name Wide Among Us?
Uh, Wide Among Us Gay Sex.
Oh.
I know that emote.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's what the name's based off of.
Alright.
Good to know.
Why didn't you get the second part?
It didn't fit?
Yeah, it didn't fit.
And I don't think they would let that.
Oh.
China.
What the fuck?
You have so many hours on Thor.
Oh, this is my Thor account.
I got the top 25.
Yeah, I was gonna say, isn't that the account you got top 25 solo queue?
Jesus.
Wait, we can let you Thor.
Mmm...
We can run 3-3.
It's...
Try 1-2.
I think if I play Thor against triple support, it wouldn't be that good.
Because at least when I'm Hawkeye, I can just one-shot the healers.
Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
We could run 3-1-2 as well.
But, oh wait, actually, we can't because you're the other... you're the third tank player.
I mean, or 2 -1 -3, I could like...
You're technically the third tank player.
Honestly, just run... just play whatever you guys are most comfortable with.
I'm just playing whatever I think will be good in the moment.
Yeah.
I think, like, for the rest of us, just play, like, your most comfortable picks.
And if you wanna swap, just swap.
At this point.
If you wanna swap and you feel like swapping is the key, just swap.
I'm just trying to go in.
I think we get freaky.
I'm just gonna go in.
Widowmantus?
We just get...
I think we do Widowmantus.
There were some teams that did scrim.
There were teams that did scrim.
I think...
Because they took it really seriously.
Yeah.
Widowmantus.
I was tired of scrimming.
And then I'll go Strange, and then we walk them down.
And everybody seemed really...
Also, like, it always seemed really busy, and we had a last-minute substitute too.
I don't know.
I feel like we need to...
I don't know what I need to comm, but, like, they've been out of position a lot.
Like, on Strange, I just solo killed their fucking Invis woman, and then solo killed their Raccoon.
Because they're just, like, walking...
Because it's like...
There's, like, top 500 players, and there's, like, Diamond players.
So, it's like...
Some of them are just, like, walking into, like, a corridor.
Yeah, it's a mix of everything.
Yeah.
And they don't respect us.
I mean, they don't have to, clearly, but, like...
We have to make them respect us.
Exactly.
Make them respect us.
Lay it all out on the table.
I'll break the toast...
I think I have a curse with any toast tournament.
Any toast tournament I participate in, I'm, like...
Except for the first one.
The very first Disguised Toast tournament I did, it was alright.
We got first place.
And then, like, it's just...
I peaked.
I peaked, and then, like...
And then everything went downhill.
I peaked at the first tournament, and then nothing was the same since.
And then...
Yeah.
I peaked at first try.
It's alright.
Like I said, I knew going in, I knew going in, because, like...
It was also, like...
We literally got our last minute substitute at...
10pm last night.
Like...
Our last minute sub was...
Was brought in at 10pm.
Because we were mess...
Like, everybody was messaging people.
Just to figure out, like...
Like, who we have to get.
And I think, like...
I think, like...
I think Jake is, like, the only Diamond player to...
In the entire, like...
In the tournament that's currently Diamond.
I don't know.
I don't remember if I saw on some of the teams that anyone else is Diamond.
But...
Because it was, like, Diamond to GM.
And I was going to get...
I messaged someone that I thought was GM, but they recently hit Celestial.
Celestial 3.
They recently hit Celestial 3.
And then...
Toast was like, sorry we can't get him.
Because we can't let Celestial 3 be in the Diamond GM spot.
And I was like, that's cool.
That's alright.
And...
And then, so, like...
Because, like, you know...
We couldn't make it today.
So we were like, alright.
We just grab anyone.
We just gotta grab somebody.
We gotta grab someone.
So he's, like, filling in for us really last minute.
But yeah.
And it's fine.
Like, I went going in knowing that it was a Conqueror team.
And teams in Conqueror teams are never actually...
They can never be fully balanced, you know?
And then, obviously, we didn't scrim.
So we didn't figure out, like, what we're comfortable with.
Which is my bad.
Because I could have asked if people would want to scrim.
But even if we did scrim, we would have lost Wig.
We would have lost Wig.
And then we were like, what do we do?
How are the motivational speeches going?
Wait, how do you know?
I just assumed that's what you were doing.
Because it's what you did last time.
I'm listening to Denzel Washington.
He's pepping me up.
Is it working?
I'm hyped.
I just did 10 push-ups.
Because DJ Khaled told me to.
Wait, do 20.
I'll do another 10 right now.
No, 20 in a row.
What's your max?
Do your max right now.
I don't know.
I do incline.
That's fine.
Okay.
I'll do 20.
I don't think he's actually doing it.
Okay, now do some burpees.
There's no way.
I am!
I don't think so.
Do some burpees.
Turn the cam on.
Turn the cam on and do it.
What's a burpee?
A burpee is where you do a jumping jack.
You jump up in the air and then you do a push-up.
Okay, I'm not doing that.
Oh, the game is supposed to start in a minute.
Are we all here?
I'm here.
Sleepy is supposed to invite me.
When we're playing on Sleepy, I fucking hate that guy.
Wait, why do you hate that guy?
Because he's cute.
I mean, we can just ban Loki.
You hate people because they're cute?
I get jealous.
Sleepy fucking invite me.
Wait, can you look me up and say if you hate me then?
He's like, I love you.
I saw your picture in our team thing.
You're kind of cute.
So you hate me?
Yeah, well, like...
A little bit.
Like, I'm from Overwatch.
I'm not cute enough to be hated?
What the fuck?
It's different!
What do you mean it's different?
Because Sleepy is like, oh yeah, I'm a catboy.
It's different.
No, he's a femboy.
Get it right.
And a catboy.
It's both.
Dude, his RuneScape name is like Catboy.
Just say I'm ugly.
I get it.
You're beautiful, bro.
It's just a different... I wasn't filled with rage, but now I am.
This game is invite only.
That's fucked up.
Use the rage to win.
I will do.
I just got motivated.
That's good.
I pulled out the motivational speech.
I lost like 50 viewers.
I'm nice in that fucking game.
Who are you missing?
Oh, wait.
Let me see.
Where are you?
Wait, didn't I have you on my friends list?
Who was invited in Lulu?
It wasn't me.
I joined off Bogr the first time.
Oh yeah, the first time.
We're getting spectated.
I don't know their team.
I just know Void plays Magneto.
Fear, Magneto.
Yeah, whatever.
I feel like these guys are respectable.
They probably play Hitscan.
Do you think they play Namor?
Maybe.
Bangchan fan?
Namor is one of the easiest characters to play.
I was like, who the fuck is Bangchan?
Oh yeah, is that Peter?
Peter plays...
I know Peter.
Actually, I don't know.
I didn't have Peter last time in the toast thing.
Isn't Peter bald now?
Yo.
No, I saw the Twitter post.
He shaved his head?
Yeah.
Wait, I don't even use Twitter anymore.
Let me see.
Are you for real?
Holy fuck, he did shave his head.
And it's not even like a clean shave.
What the hell?
Wait, why is this one Oregon?
Is that normal?
I mean, that's fine for you guys, I think.
I'm eastbound here.
Look at this.
Are y'all ready?
I don't know if we're all ready or not.
Yeah.
Are y'all here?
I'm back.
You sound so fucking depressed.
I'm ready.
What do you mean?
I'm good to go.
I'm here.
That sounded so depressing.
We're down three stocks.
This guy is already jumping off the map.
He's like, he's feeling...
I'm ready.
He's feeling PTSD from Smash Bros right now.
Oh wait, I'm not doing bans, am I?
Am I the team guy?
It's whoever is in the faction.
I don't even know that.
Remember when Leshota was always the one doing bans there?
Right, yeah.
We are... I assume everybody's here.
I'm just gonna... If we're not, then that's okay.
We have the whole ban phase for people to get back.
But what if the person banning is gone?
Then we'll jump then, I guess.
Fuck us.
Can we ask for a reset?
No, we go in with no bans.
Let's make it quick play.
I'm not afraid.
We were doing this map again?
Oh, we are.
The whole club was looking at her.
Dude, that's crazy.
This one's domination, so we're not...
Oh yeah, it's domination, yeah.
I was like, what?
This again?
So who banned first?
Glorp, ban, ban...
Fuck Snoopy, ban Loki.
Fuck him.
Us against the world.
I don't want him to play the game that he wants to play.
What the Glorp?
Why'd they ban Hawkeye?
I guess I don't want a new one-shot.
Were they watching my last game?
I mean, Hawkeye is always good against teams that are SR around the place.
Alright, who wants their character protected?
Who wants to protect their character?
IDK.
We protect Widow.
Yo, I'm down.
Let's fucking throw.
Up to you guys, let me know.
There's no way they banned Hawkeye and Widow.
That'd be insane.
I mean, we could protect Strange.
Yeah, Strange is fine.
I was gonna do Widow, I honestly don't care.
Dude, play Widow, play whatever you want.
Just play whatever you want, guys.
Something will work out.
Something nice will happen.
Should we ban Nemore?
Yeah, just ban Nemore.
I don't want to play against Nemore anyway.
Real talk, no bans.
Just play.
We just did all two.
Wait, what if I go Iron Fist?
Oh, fuck, let's do it.
Just do it, it's Mr. Heroes.
Cheaper town hall!
Oh, nevermind.
I don't get my thing.
Okay, cool.
Why did we ban Luna?
We already banned...
I guess they don't want defensive.
Okay.
Protect Strange, lock Magneto.
Yeah, fuck this.
I'm done.
Holy!
Run it.
They're all lords!
I only have Ward.
If it doesn't work, I'm just selfless.
This is definitely not enough.
Okay, I can't play Mantis.
Wait, we can do Mantis-Atom thoughts?
Yeah, we can.
Do you want to go Magneto?
I mean, I don't really...
We go Mantis-Atom, we need triple support.
Yeah, we need triple support.
Yeah, no, I like this, I like this.
Alright, fuck it!
Fuck it, ball up.
Fuck it, let's ball!
Oh my god, all the DPS.
Let's fucking ball!
Yo, hit them shots!
It's West Coast now, so I'm lagging, you're good.
Okay.
Wait, it's West Coast?
It should automatically be Virginia.
I'm 75 ping, brother.
Wait, what the fuck?
Okay, whatever, it doesn't matter.
Fuck it, ball up.
Yeah, let's ball it, I don't care anymore.
Restart the lobby.
Plus $1,000.
It's okay, we don't have EU players, it's okay.
If we lose the game, we can blame it, we're like, yo, we're EU.
What the fuck?
I'll never say I'm EU.
Where are they?
Port me, portal me.
We're running triple support with, I think...
They have Atom.
Not Atom, uh...
Oh, they do have Atom, but Starlord too.
Hey, look, ping!
Let's contest point here.
Nice, we got ping.
You're not going to die, you're not going to die.
Where's my Widow?
Okay, there he is.
Yo, Starlord, Starlord, Starlord!
There's so many things going on on my screen.
I have my ult.
I mean, we could...
We could get a pick.
I'm on it.
I'm already told.
Yeah, no, I mean...
Haha, we were on triple support.
We farmed that fast.
No, we got a bubble!
Restart, restart, restart.
Let's just use...
I guess we'll use support as defensive.
All right, Strange, here's day three.
Um, there's three as well.
So it doesn't...
It's better to...
Get damage boosted.
We're all here.
Same push up.
Moving up.
Oh, Coney, you are taking so much damage.
Yeah, I can't, I can't...
Oh, I just got sedated!
I'll swap, but...
I'll swap to mag, because I can't...
I got my ult.
Just walking up to them.
Yeah.
They're low!
Oh, she got it off!
All right, she got the Riz off, though.
I don't know where the Riz is.
Damn, that bubble, man.
I can't heal you there.
Nice, Riz.
Nice.
We got bubbled.
Manta?
No.
It's all healing, but...
Back up!
Oh...
We don't have defensive for it, other than...
I mean, we got nice soulbond.
That's a good soulbond.
Holy shit.
Nice.
Got him.
Hey, W kills!
W kills!
Okay...
They're gonna have...
They're gonna mag ult here.
I got ult.
I don't have ult yet.
Okay, double time.
Careful, Coney.
Careful, Coney, you're one!
Ah, my god.
Try to jump back.
If you can, give me...
Okay, I have to use this.
I missed him though.
Oh.
They're gonna...
They're gonna thing ult after.
Oh, nice cancel.
Do I stay clobbering?
Someone has to...
Someone has to touch point!
One of the tanks has to touch!
Oh.
I can run up without him.
You're fine, you're fine.
Look, look, Starlord!
He's like half.
We are undefeatable!
Oh, that's three ults.
That's three fucking ults.
That's fucking crazy.
I should have rez, but fuck it.
Yeah, I'll split to mag.
I just...
I had ult, so I was trying to save it, but...
Yeah, I can't solo tank on thing, because I just get exploded.
Yeah.
I'll swap.
No, yeah.
Thing solo tank is like...
definitely the hardest to play.
I mean...
Can I strange here?
I think we should lock him down.
Yeah, no.
I'm just going to swap to another support then.
Because they only had...
What was their damage?
Was it Starlord?
It was Starlord, yeah.
Starlord and thing.
You just have to swap off Widow, because Widow is not good with Elementals.
Yeah.
I have point flip so often.
Like, we have to make sure at least one tank stays on point.
Even if you think you're going to die, it's better to just stay on point.
Last game, we didn't have a tank up.
Yeah.
Because I was dead and coming back, and we didn't have another tank to touch point.
Oh, yeah.
You were...
We were one tank, dude.
That's why we didn't get it last time.
Do you want to drop?
Starlord is on my left side.
I'm going to drop.
Okay.
I'm looking back.
Hey, what's happening?
They're all just running at us.
They're on top of us.
They're all just running.
I got slapped.
They just, like, ran at us.
There was nothing we could do there.
They're going to have Tingle here.
Nice.
I guess I'll ult first.
Whenever...
Yeah.
They're going to have Tingle.
I pulled back, but...
Careful of Tingle.
I'm off guard here.
Hey, can we walk up?
Give this fucking Starlord ult.
I'm walking up.
I'm going to look for Agumon.
I don't have ult for that.
I ult.
My ult is on point.
I got you.
Oh, he went push for us.
What's up, Papa?
I was a little lucky.
Get this Mag.
You only have local kills there.
You're down.
Oh, wait, they rez.
They still have Mag ult.
Unless they use it.
One portal.
Can we portal?
You have to portal now.
You have to portal now if you want to.
Back up, back up, back up.
Oh, we got protected.
Let me know if he's running.
We got bodyblocked because he can't interrupt this.
I'm trying to heal you guys as best as I can.
Get on the point, get on the point.
Fuck, he saw me.
That's crazy.
Warm up.
Get a warm up.
I don't know.
I mean, it's just the DPS diff and I'm not that good enough.
You were a last minute sub, so it's alright.
You literally came into the server at like 10pm last night.
It's alright.
I was not planning on playing in this, but it's all good.
You're fine.
It's fine.
You get $3,000.
Yeah, $3,000.
That's all that matters.
Next match is Flats.
Flats has been...
He told me he's gonna go help out at charity, so...
Flats' team has been scrimming, by the way, so they're gonna be extra sweaty.
Fuck it.
Yeah, fuck it.
I don't know who's on his team, because I need to get invited to his server.
I'm gonna go Meg this game, I think.
How's that?
I think I need more.
I think we need to peel, or I need to peel more.
Because I'm doing as much as I can on Strange.
But it doesn't matter.
Like, Agamotto, I killed one and I still lose.
It doesn't really matter, because they have so much healing.
I mean, they do triple support.
It's more so of just like...
Get out of my lobby.
We could just mirror triple support at that point.
Does anyone have anybody on Flats' team added?
Because I don't... they didn't add me.
I don't think so.
It's Flats...
Flats, Super, WeDid, Poe, Selene, and FanFan.
If anybody has them.
Let me see if I can add Flats right now.
Flats, don't fight me.
Guys, it's okay.
I got a ranked squad after this.
If I lose in rank, it's okay.
I guess I'll crash out.
It's okay.
Guys, I'm crashing out so much right now.
So... wait, no, it's not out yet?
No!
I was going to buy the low-key costume.
I was like, I'm going to crash out so hard.
I'm going to buy the low-key costume.
I'm going to live with my free money.
Also, I'm going to use the bathtub right back.
Dude, honestly...
If they do like cringe triple healer every game, I might go Groot.
Just like wall the tank off.
Groot is good against triple heal.
Yeah, I just only have like five hours on him, but like, that's fine.
I believe.
As long as I think his ult is grav, so...
The range is...
It does have a pretty big suck.
Yeah, it does.
It's crazy that people think I chose this team.
But I think like the only thing they asked me was like, you want to share it for us?
I was like, yeah.
And then I found out Kony was part of it.
I was like, yeah, sure.
Bring Kony in my team.
But Kony was already in the tournament.
I was like, I want to play with Kony again.
Um...
But like, that's crazy people think that I stacked my team, but it was literally randomly assigned.
And stuff.
Yeah, it's randomized.
It's randomized except for me, Surefour, and Kony.
I'm like, how?
It's a creator cup.
How am I stacked?
I recently was like...
I know some team actually...
I was told that some teams actually picked all their players.
Um...
They actually like hand-picked the players they want in their team.
And everything too.
For me, I was just like...
Cause like, when I invited Surefour, Surefour was like, oh wait, you're captain?
I thought you had to pick everybody.
I was like, no, I'm just randomized.
I didn't even know I was captain.
I didn't even...
Those just gave me teammates.
I was just like, okay.
I was just like...
And Surefour was like, hey, I feel weird.
Cause you know, everybody in the captain slot is an actual pro player.
Or has played pro in the past.
And I'm just...
I'm just...
I'm just their keeper.
I was just like, I feel...
This is awkward.
I'm just an anim...
I'm just a little guy.
So like, I didn't...
I know some teams handpicked their teammates, but I didn't.
I was randomly assigned teammates and stuff.
So we're just making the best of it.
I literally came in knowing that it's a creator tournament.
And...
The first place just gets $700 more.
I mean, not just.
But it's not a huge gap in between first and last place.
So I'm just like, I'm fine with that.
Who the fuck?
Random... What?
Okay.
Who the fuck is this guy?
What the fuck?
I thought that was for the lobby.
I was like, what is this?
Is this the lobby?
I was thinking about this, right?
Adam Warlock, he's the perfect human, right?
He has the same hairline as me, so does that mean I'm the perfect human?
Are you gold?
Oh, they're still in the game, that's why.
I haven't died yet, but I can try.
Well, I'm not going to try.
I'm not going to try, but when I die, I'll try to cocoon.
I'm trying to like... because when I'm IGL-ing, it's very serious, too.
So I can't fuck around because I'm IGL-ing.
So it's harder to bring the mood up when I have to IGL for this.
Oh, because they use the Johnny Storm combo and it just lasts a long time?
That's why I was like, just put whatever the fuck you want.
You can still cocoon after.
That thing lasts a while.
Wait, guys, let me show you my adventures last night playing with Korean players.
Wait, if Jeff eats you, I think you can cocoon.
So for those who don't know...
For those who don't know, Choppa is on the same team as FunFun and DDoBi.
I'm working on that.
I have the same musculature, though.
So I just need to paint myself gold.
So when I was playing with Choppa, we actually went against FunFun.
I mean, I'm out all day.
Let me show you guys.
I'm not streaming, I work in construction.
Wait, you double stacked that shit?
I didn't play with them the entire time, though, because they had to go.
Let me show you guys.
We've got a compulsive liar on our team.
I'm not a liar, I'm a storyteller.
An entertainer.
That wasn't a story, that was just lying.
Let me show you a story in three parts.
Like a hypothetical.
I was asking you a genuine question and you just answered with a genuine lie.
No, I don't go outside that much, but I was a student.
And then this is part two.
Okay, what happened?
So I'm in my last year.
Law.
Okay.
I'm a liar, yeah.
No wonder you're not good at lying.
Part three of the story.
Pursue education.
Very good.
And then this is part three.
Do we need to invite them?
Or do we need to invite them?
I think they're inviting us.
They're still in game, so I'm just waiting.
They're still in game, so I'm waiting for Vlads.
Okay.
But was the law school also a lie?
No.
Mercy carry, it's me.
How do I know if you're telling the truth or not?
Because I'm Canadian.
You basically played against...
I'm Canadian now.
Okay, there we go.
You play Genshin, so I'm just going to assume you always lie.
Whoa, I played Overwatch.
That's true.
Literally just spending your money has rotted your brain.
Okay, I'm free to play.
Okay, that's a lie.
Free to play is even worse.
That's what I'm saying, bro.
If you're free to play a player in a gacha game, that's like true mental illness.
Yeah, bro, just put the money in the bag.
No, the whole point of gacha games is to be like...
Normies buy Gucci and Rolexes to flex.
Weebs buy characters in a video game.
That's true.
So if you're free to play a player...
Why the fuck did you decline the invite to the lobby?
Because I'm fucking alt-tabbed.
Get the fuck in.
Okay, let's see.
How about next time you say, hey, I invited you.
No, you should have your game up all the time.
You think I'm just going to be staring at this fucking screen while we're just AFK while I'm down 05 or 06, whatever we are?
We're 05.
It's okay, we'll be 07.
We're about to be 1 and 5.
Nah, we can beat these guys.
Dude, we can.
Just ban Wolverine.
I don't want to fucking deal with Super's Wolverine right now.
I'm praying.
We're going to be 1 and 5.
It's okay.
Who are you missing?
Can I flank Jeff again?
I'm not one for you to ask me for permission.
Just do whatever the fuck you want, guys.
Yippee!
This is anarchy.
We're anarchists now.
We're anarchists.
Behold, Darkchild!
Oh, we're missing...
Let me change over.
I'm sure these guys are honest men and we got a strange mirror.
That'd be flat to play strange.
Thank God.
They have played a lot of The Thing.
Yo, we played The Thing.
We literally played strange thing versus strange thing.
They make Nito the Thing.
They make Mag the Thing.
Mag is better with The Thing.
Yeah, I know, but I want to play strange.
I'll go Mag.
You can play strange.
If you want to play strange, play strange.
Like Mag v.
Mag, I'm like, I know what to do.
Strange v.
Strange, I like whip my cock out.
Ready?
Dude, Boger went Mag.
Okay.
No, this character's too broken.
I gotta go Magneto.
Bye, the Yacht.
We're missing one person and they're not on my friends list.
Saj.
Wait, how come I didn't see Glorpfan in here?
I'm here.
Oh, there you are.
Alright, are we all ready?
Yes!
Coney, do you really want to lose to Super?
Now he's hyped.
Coney doesn't want to lose to Super.
He made a video about him and now he's...
Yeah, but we'll beat him.
That's fine.
I'll make a video about how Super's ass.
They scrimmed, so they might be a little more coordinated.
Oh no!
Wait, I saw them.
I watched one of their games and Super was on fucking Thing and they got clapped.
Yeah, but he's their DPS player technically.
Oh, okay.
I saw their scrims.
He plays DPS in ranked too.
If he gets to play Wolverine.
That's why I won't ban Wolverine because that's his main DPS role.
Starting.
I fucking hate this map.
Yeah, this one sucks.
That big ass hallway.
Trif, are you going Jeff?
I'll suss it out.
What do you want to do?
Are we finally running Widowmantis?
I don't think I can play Jeff on this map.
I don't know if Jeff is here.
Jake, you're banning.
Ban Wolverine.
Goodbye Wolverine.
We protect Jeff?
This map is okay for Jeff, unfortunately.
Yeah, it's hard to flank on this map.
No, it's not hard to flank.
It's just environmental for my ult.
Who are we saving?
Jeff.
We're going to save whatever your hearts desire because we don't really have a specific character we want to save.
We can save whatever.
I mean, we can save Matt.
What?
Why can't we do Widowmantis?
Well, I'm pretty sure they looked at Tonka's profile and saw he was a Widowmantric.
I mean...
It is what it is.
Matt is crazy.
I do not get to play at all good.
Wait, there is one flank I can do.
What the hell?
Someone's dying.
What?
Is that a firearm?
Are one of you guys in EMT?
Are you at work?
I could flank Loki.
Should I save Loki?
No, it's Doki.
Doki is getting flatlined.
I don't know.
Whatever you want, bro.
Our team captain is dead.
Loki.
Okay.
Who am I banning?
Just ban Namor.
Fuck it.
Where is he?
We should just say he lagged out.
Yeah, I wrote our captain died, Namor.
Okay, our mental is cooked.
Guys, lock in!
Oh, it actually is a fire alarm.
Oh, okay.
Holy.
Turn that shit back on if you don't have to get kicked out.
Wait, they didn't ban either.
I'll listen to the beeps.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Good bans.
They banned Venom.
This is fun.
You guys crumbled down when I stopped.
I don't understand.
How?
Oh my god.
I'm not a team leader.
I heard the fire alarm and it scared me.
Wait, fuck it.
I'm going Mr. Fantastic.
Nah, I'm going Voink.
I'm going.
Fuck it.
This one, I can just die in the fire.
Is it like a real alarm?
Are you okay?
Keep it on!
No, sometimes it's not real.
I can't tell anymore.
Is it like a test alarm?
I can't tell.
Maybe it's like syncupation.
Maybe we need it to be playing so it gets everyone's heads just constantly moving.
I'm actually locked in now.
I'm actually locked in.
I think we should wait.
It's fine, right?
No, we fight.
We go.
Okay.
This guy's talking in game too.
That's how locked in he is.
I think we go right on this map, but I don't know.
Actually, no.
I do know.
I'm IGL.
We go right.
Type shit.
We go up here.
Follow the captain!
Choo-choo!
All aboard!
These guys are probably like, man, they're going right.
Look mag!
Thing!
I'm on thing!
Oh, I'm getting cooked.
Look at mag!
Yeah, mag could die.
Mag could die.
Alright, shield.
I'm so weak.
Hella's like kind of frontline map.
The healers are like... Can we look Hella?
Can we look Hella?
I got Hella.
Think, think, think, think, think, think.
Maybe healers?
Can we walk up to healers?
Healers?
Got it.
Oh,
I'm fucking beating the shit out of them.
I busted on them.
All we needed was Iron Face.
I'm beating the shit out of them.
Shit.
I'm walking up.
They're going to stagger.
I feel it.
No, these guys scrimmed.
They did scrim.
They did.
Yo, can we hear the fire alarm real quick?
Sure.
We have to win or America's under siege.
You ult first.
Okay.
Am I to ult this?
Yo, fight this Hella.
Yeah, I see the full backline here.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
Oh, they got...
Okay, well...
I'm getting them.
I'm fucking them up.
I'm beating the shit out of them.
Walk them down.
Oh my god.
We have to win or I'm going to get clipped by fucking super TF Yowie.
Wait, this might be our win, boys.
Wait.
I'm going in.
Fire alarm.
Yo, you're stuck in there.
There's a wall.
They haven't killed anybody yet.
Oh no, not in this small asshole.
Wait.
I got pushed.
Wait, I need help.
I have a small woman.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, good regroup.
I hate him as a woman.
She just pulls you in.
GG.
Yeah, she'd do that.
I know.
Damn, stayed on that cart a while, though.
Are we regrouping?
High performance.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
Our Luna isn't here.
Oh, good.
On the way, on the way, on the way.
Oh, big pull!
I'm blocking healing.
No, I'm not.
I lied.
Wait, I'm low.
I have ult.
I'm gonna... I'm ulting back.
I'm waiting, waiting.
I'm ulting when this is up.
I have no shield.
I can't block it.
I can block a bit now.
Thing's on me in the back.
Oh, god.
I think we might be resetting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I hit a wall.
Okay.
All good.
We walk up.
Ryke with me.
Oh, I got Ryke'd.
I think he was going for you.
Thing is top right.
I'm looking for Agamotto.
Agamotto?
Oh, my god.
Jesus.
I could get a big Agamotto here, but...
Look, I really want to ult.
Okay.
Wait, let me walk up first this time.
Just, like, keep me healthy.
And then you can jump to me, Coney, when I get close.
Yep.
I'm gonna Agamotto.
I just... I know they're fucking invis gonna push me away.
Okay, I'm gonna ult and distract them and then maybe...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, you ult and then I ult.
Let me walk up.
Yeah, get ready to push.
Yeah, I'm close.
Let's pause.
I'm here.
Wait.
I'm low.
Oh,
my soul fucking beat.
Oh, yeah.
Like, I feel it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I don't need to shoot him.
I'll just beat the shit out of him.
I'm thinking.
I can't fly up.
Oh, my...
I'm using mine.
I'm looking Hella.
Yeah, I see Hella.
I'm looking...
Mag can die.
No, it didn't do the auto-track kick.
Orly on the left.
Both...
Two of the healers are dead.
Mag can...
Invis, invis is beating.
I'm blocking it.
They're blocking?
Strange on cart.
Oh...
I can only have Luna right now.
He's one.
Yay.
Probably try to shoot both here.
I'm trying to get both.
Got it.
I'm about to get Agumoto.
Sue, Sue, Sue.
Are we here?
Can I Agumoto?
Ah, I saw his bite.
Might as well.
Ah, I can't really get much there.
Last bite.
Yeah, I know.
Sturge can die, Sturge can die, Sturge can die.
Damn.
Is this the all of them?
Ah, man.
Guys, the fire alarm hasn't stopped.
I'm a...
I mean, we literally don't care about hearing it.
You know you can talk, right?
Guys.
No, but the fire alarm hasn't stopped.
Who cares?
I'm a little...
I don't think this is a false alarm anymore.
I...
You have to...
I mean, we could replay one round.
I...
I don't know.
Hey, if you have to go, you gotta go.
I mean, if it's a fire, you should probably...
I don't...
I don't know.
They're saying they cheated.
Aw.
Aw, they're gonna get trouble.
They did cheat.
Aw.
Ha ha ha.
Use money from tournament for a new apartment.
Mmm, wait.
I'm checking if they're portaling.
They're not portaling.
Wise.
Hey, I guess...
Are you...
I mean, lock-in, I guess, but...
Oh, there goes Jeff.
I could go mag here if I die.
Patoot, patoot, patoot.
Oh, we can kill mag.
Oh my god, he fucking owned me.
Wow.
No way.
Alarm stopped.
Getting away with one HP.
The alarm stopped?
Yippee!
I think I have more kills.
We were safe.
They're so killable there.
Alright.
Yeah.
I didn't say Jeff was bad on this map.
Oh, it's good for first point.
Oh, okay.
But we all died.
Yeah, sadge.
That's life.
It is what it is.
Okay, we hold this.
Like the champions we are.
I don't want to take this base.
We down?
I'm always down.
Link me up.
I'm trying my best to heal all of you.
You're all so very low.
I'll ult first.
Okay.
Block my part.
Oh, that's huge.
Oh, you have shield.
No!
Oh, my.
I think we just fucking reset here.
I can portal.
We have to reset.
I just got a reminder.
What's the reminder?
During God of Death, Hela...
I can't read.
I'm going to portal here.
Yeah, we're waiting.
We're waiting for portal.
Coney, we're portaling.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm going to same spot they portaled.
Actually, it's a bit different.
It's his last fight anyway.
I'm going to look for Agumon.
What the fuck?
I didn't even see that.
I'm low.
I'm trying to.
Walking is healing?
Nope.
We don't have any support ults for this.
No.
That's huge.
We have to look closer.
Adam's cocooning on our left.
Adam is one.
We got Adam.
He's fine.
No more ults.
Hela to the right.
Technically, we can kill that.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, we can still.
Nice.
We have to stack these guys.
Much respect.
Every game has been triple healer.
Why didn't we...
Because it's meta.
Why are we 2-2-2?
We can't because...
Why is the team 2-2-2?
We can't because we don't have a...
We don't have a secondary tank player.
I'm seeing that adventure just in like 2-1-3.
I'm fighting...
I have ult.
They have...
They have thing ult too.
Oh, I couldn't get to you there.
Help Coney.
He has ult too.
We walk on Adam.
Yup.
I have to...
We are...
Guys.
We have a thing.
Here's the thing.
Winnable.
Like, we got to stop protecting these guys.
We walked into their backline.
Oh, nevermind.
Yeah, we can't...
We can't push our dmg back.
We can't do both.
Yeah, but me and the Hela were trapped on front.
That's why.
Nagamoto after this.
I see you guys.
We need it.
Big.
Okay.
Gosh, cut that out, man.
We have no supports.
Coming back right now.
I'm just trying to stall.
I've frozen, but I can't live.
Bleh.
I've fallen three seconds.
I don't think we can touch.
Warm up.
That was unlucky.
The universe didn't want us to win that.
Yeah, that's life sometimes, isn't it?
Should I just, like, play a healer?
I have 13 final hits.
Like, they're just getting fucking killed.
Yeah, you should go check outside.
The fire is burning up my building right now.
I'll be right back.
Aight.
I'm gonna go pee.
I mean, the elevators are working, so I assume it's not a fire.
I think if it was a real fire, somebody would've gotcha.
Somebody would've been like, hey, it's a real fire.
I feel like they would've said stuff, because you can say stuff in the intercom with the fire alarm.
And nobody's saying anything.
What if the intercom burned?
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
What if there's aliens?
Hello?
I just wanted him to think about what he said there.
Alright.
Give me your money.
I feel like Glorp would sound more higher-pitched.
Wouldn't Glorp be a cat, too?
You have to meow now.
No, but it's like a smart cat.
Like, it's an alien.
It can speak every language.
You gotta meow.
I won't believe you're Glorp until you meow.
I can't meow.
I'm inviting people in.
What the hell
is this?
Okay, I invited everybody.
Booger has to fucking leave.
He's still here.
I don't think it's a natural fire.
iPhone 8 loser.
That's Calvin.
Oh, shit.
Because, like...
Because there were people that went back to their apartment.
They went back to their room.
So, they went back to their...
I saw one person, like, come out of the elevator.
I saw some people come out of the elevator to go back to their room.
So, I assume everything is okay.
I just think... I don't know.
Maybe, like, someone fucking started a mini-fire or something.
And it was just okay.
I don't know.
But, like, I'm okay now.
Are we all ready?
Yeah.
We are...
Wait, do we know what we ban?
I don't know anyone here except Shoto.
They like playing Starlord.
Just ban Starlord, then.
And then Loki.
Alright, I'm done.
Or...
Shoto's Loki one trick.
He can play fucking Namor.
He was a really good Namor player in the VTuber Rivals.
Because I had him on my team.
Well, he's playing support, though.
Oh, is he a support on this team?
So, no bans.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it's a Loki one trick.
We could go Loki, then.
I don't mind whatever.
No bans!
So, I'm not banning anyone.
I don't care.
It's the last game.
And I'm...
It's LG here.
I mean, if we win the...
Just ban Loki.
Fuck it.
Just fuck over Shoto, I guess.
Okay, fuck it.
We actually can't go 007.
Like, we have to win.
Well, then we better freaking win.
Alright, then you IGL.
You IGL.
Yes!
I just play the game.
Okay, I said don't do it.
Alright, what do you want to protect, IGL?
Let's protect...
Our...
Honestly, Luna, bro.
They've been banning Luna.
You want to protect Luna?
No, I don't care.
I don't think we need to protect anything.
They protected Star-Lord.
Mag, maybe?
Are we going Mag?
I can protect Mag.
But are we going Mag?
Well, I don't know.
Kone, are you doing Mag or Thing?
Uh, I'm good with either.
Bam, whatever.
I don't care.
I mean, I'll just...
I'll just say Mag.
I'm good with...
Yeah, just say Mag.
Just ban Adam Warlock if you don't want to deal with triple Rescomp.
Yeah, they are going Star-Lord.
I could ban Adam then.
Or Mantis.
Well, Adam gives the Res.
IGL, what do you think?
Whatever you think is best.
Make the call.
Yeah, yeah, get Adam out of here.
It's your call, coach.
Get that hot, oiled up man out of here.
Ban Jeff?
He's oiled?
Oh.
I'll fucking kick you off the team.
Okay.
Van of Tech Cactuses.
One win.
Alright, let's do it.
Let's do it big.
Okay.
That's okay.
Okay, we have to go Mag if we protected him.
Magnetis.
Yeah, I think we can keep Invis.
I like this.
Actually, I'm down for Mag.
You go Strange.
I kind of want to play Mag here.
Yes sir, yes sir.
I'm stuck in an animation.
It's probably going to be bullshit on the bridge, high ground.
I'm going to jump up on them.
And then whoever can follow can follow.
Like Psylocke or whatever.
And then Magneto just keep our support safe.
Yeah, okay.
I play Strange with Aston usually.
I'm going to do that this game.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
I'm going.
Hangover.
Oh, they have Groot.
They didn't ban you, did they?
We didn't ban anyone, Groot.
So they're going to use combo.
Their support can up heal it.
Baby, I'm paying on you tonight.
Don't let go tonight.
Don't let go.
Just shoot a wall at the wall here.
At the choke.
Is there no more fucking turret top left?
Uh oh.
There's wall.
I'm going to make space here.
I'm walking on...
Nevermind, I got pushed.
I'm going to walk on Groot.
I'm on Groot.
There's a Starlord on the support.
I'm shielding healing.
Shoot him.
There's a Starlord on support.
I got Magged.
I kidnapped for Groot.
Alright, I have to walk.
I'm walking back.
There's a Starlord behind us.
There's a Starlord.
I got him.
He's just going to be trying to go in with E bubble every time.
Yeah, so annoying.
We might have to look back at the Starlord.
I have ult.
I'm just going to go straight in.
I'm not here yet.
Yeah, but I will bring...
Kidnap the Groot.
Four.
Three.
Bye.
Two.
One.
I died right when I got my ult.
Oh, that's unlucky.
I was 1% off from Mag ult.
I could have caught that.
They still have Invis ult.
And they have Namor ult.
They didn't use Namor ult.
Actually, they're just going to Groot all of us now.
No, they used it.
They used it.
Oh, okay.
Bad, bad, bad.
I'm opening a portal.
They know they're backing up.
I'm going to do the different high ground.
Wait, there's someone right above us.
Luna.
Look top right.
Oh, she dropped.
No, she's still there.
Okay.
I froze somebody.
And we're in a bubble.
There's more of the Luna up there.
Oh, I got caught in the ceiling.
The house rebuilt itself.
Blocked it.
There's supports at the front.
The supports are just at the front line.
With the Namor.
I got the Namor.
Let's get one down.
I'm one.
Ow.
Look, Mag.
I'm all here.
I'm just going to wait.
Probably pressure healers here.
I'm just going to try.
I'll try ulting the Gruul.
Because they don't have Namor yet.
They don't have Namor.
Get the Gruul.
Three, two, one.
No more ults.
Damn.
Good luck, Starlord.
Yeah, let them use stuff, I guess.
I have Agumon.
I have three ults coming.
Can win with the Viz ult, probably.
They have Namor ult here.
Yeah.
I'm at 80%.
We can save Bubble to get aggro.
And use it on the Diver.
I'll look for Agumon.
Shooting squids.
Walking up.
Starlord behind us.
Keep me up.
I'm trying to.
Everyone's weak.
Do we have shield?
I only got thing.
Sorry.
Wait, if this can die.
Oh, well this is good.
Hey, all good?
Did we drop?
Yeah.
Is this one ITLing?
I know it's not.
Yo, drawable?
I feel like first fight we should have won, though.
I don't know what happened.
For the first fight.
Life.
Life happens.
The first fight the Starlord was on me, Lulu, and Jake.
So we couldn't progress forward.
It was the Starlord E'd all three of us.
And me and Lulu called him out behind us.
Yeah, I'm Wolverine.
I can't kill a Starlord.
Yeah.
Honestly, fuck it.
I'll send Groot.
Might as well, bro.
Push a Groot.
I am Groot!
Fucking walled, loser.
Sorry.
Fucked up.
Okay.
That was friendly fire.
Yeah.
That was practicing.
Hydra.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
A little help, please.
Today, we fight as allies.
Do not
die.
The Namor is above, on high ground.
We have Squeezed behind us.
Okay, Starlord down.
Omath, you're dying.
I'm gonna try to keep you up.
Namor on the right, Namor on the right.
Yeah.
Nice.
Walking up.
Yeah.
Starlord.
Nice.
I need help here.
Okay, we can back up.
Namor top right.
They're gonna try and do the Namor combo here.
They don't have it, but they'll have it.
I'm stuck.
Wait, where the fuck am I?
We have two people on us.
We need shield for our invis.
I'm 88.
I don't know if I can get in time.
I can't get in time.
I'm 97.
That is crazy.
I have ults.
We can somehow stay alive.
Can you touch?
Oh, good.
Warm up.
This is warm up for my rank.
We're ready for day two.
We're lower bracket now, it's fine.
Oh, true, true.
This is seeding, right?
Hey guys, we won $1,000 and that's all that matters.
We won $1,000 each.
Yippee!
Yeah, money!
We're winners.
Oh, we won!
Yippee!
That was a good warm up.
Dude, at the end there though, I got fucking stuck in a corner.
I couldn't move.
I don't know what happened.
Hey, that's life sometimes.
It's life.
That's just life.
This team scrimmed too, so they were very coordinated because of it.
Yeah.
Alright, next time we scrim.
All good.
Yeah.
We run it back.
GG's, guys.
GG's.
GG's, everybody.
Nice playing.
GG's, guys.
Nice meeting you guys.
Yeah.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Cheers.
It's okay, guys.
I had my cope ready.
I knew going in, I was like, I'm ready to cope.
I'm...
It's alright, guys.
I'm warmed up for rank, but sadly, the group I wanted to play with is still scrimming right now.
And will not be...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Alright, guys.
Wait, are you going to be finished?
When we'll finish...
We went 0-7.
I'm warmed up.
I'm so...
I'm so warmed up right now.
It's okay, guys.
In the end, at least I have this.
Wait, am I still higher than Hogs?
Wait, did he play rank?
There's no fucking way.
Did Hogs play rank?
Okay, wait.
No, he fucking lost.
Oh, nice.
He lost.
Good.
As long...
As long as Hogs is not above me, I'm fine with that.
I...
It's okay.
I was...
I knew going in that it was going to be really rough because we did have someone drop out at the last minute.
So, I knew going in it was not going to be like...
Because, like, a Diamond DPS player versus a...
Not like...
Because, like, the majority of the DPS players were not the Diamond players.
Or they were GM or, like, GM and almost Celestial.
So, I was like...
I went in knowing that it was going to be very rough.
So, like, that's why I was like, that's alright.
And, like...
And, like, I did get, like...
I did get a little annoyed at some points because I was getting counter-called.
And I was just like, we are dying behind us.
But I was just like, it's okay.
Everybody is learning.
Everybody is learning right now.
Yeah, the Vi...
Like, I tried.
I tried my best.
And at that point, I was like, you IGL.
I was like, it's not that easy.
It's not that fun to IGL.
Yeah.
But it's alright.
It's okay.
I knew...
No, you can't win every tournament.
I did my best.
And then I was just like, play whatever you're comfortable in.
Because if we try to play meta, it wasn't going to work.
I knew playing meta...
I knew playing meta was not going to be it because everybody was stuck in a specific role.
Other teams could easily go three supports, two tanks.
But we can't do that because we only have two tank players.
We only had two tank players.
So...
So I was just like, well, we can't go two...
One, two, three was not going to be it.
I knew one, two, three was not going to be it.
Because it's just going to be really rough for the frontline.
Especially when their main tank player is the actual good tank player.
It's the actual high ranker.
So I was like, it's going to be really rough.
Our one tank was just going to get bullied by their high ranker tank player.
So we had to run...
Going three supports is not going to work if we only have one tank.
And everything.
And I think we had...
I just knew it was stacked against me.
And I went in being like, okay.
Okay, at least I win a thousand dollars.
Why did you count as pro?
I don't know.
I felt like Surefour should have been counted as a pro.
I know Rivals invited me to do this tournament too.
I know I said, oh, I want to join.
But the devs at Marble Rivals personally DMed me asking me to join the Disguised Toast tournament.
So I was like, all right, cool.
Okay, I'll try.
I'll try again.
And that's why I messaged.
I was like, yo, can I join in?
Do you still have a spot?
And so I was just like, I'll fuck it.
I'll do it again.
I did.
I asked to not be put in the pro category.
I asked to be put in the Celestial category.
Because I saw who were in the pro categories.
And I was like, I shouldn't count it as that.
Because I'm a support player.
And I know Sleepy was in the support pro category.
But he's literally signed to Envy right now.
Envy was in Overwatch League.
But I don't know why.
I think they just want to put my name on there too.
I think they want to put my name on there just because Marble Rivals invited me to the tournament.
But it was fine.
I knew going in.
That's why I was trying not to be too down about it.
Obviously, it's hard to pick up the vibes when the vibes were really low already.
I tried to pick up the vibes, but then the vibes were very low.
So I was just like, I don't know what to do.
I was just like, I don't know what to do.
And some teams did get to pick their teammate.
Get to pick who they wanted to play with and stuff.
I also think if Wig was there, he would definitely help with the vibes.
But we made do with what we had.
It also sucks to be a last minute sub too.
It also really sucks to be a last minute substitute in a tournament.
Because obviously, they'll think it's my fault and stuff like that.
But we literally had to message people.
Me as well.
Because I was trying to help Toast find a substitute.
So me and Toast were trying to find substitutes for one to two hours.
And it had to be on my team, obviously.
It had to be my team, obviously.
I'm just bad luck at that point for Toast tournaments.
I also didn't research at all.
I took this one really chill compared to the YouTuber Rivals.
To be fair, I shouldn't have because this one has more money involved.
But it's literally $700 more.
I mean, it's still $700 more.
But I figured, oh, it's a creator tournament.
So it's more about having fun with other creators.
Backline.
Yeah, the backline was just really rough for the backline.
Lulu and I called out backline flank all the time.
I think if we scrimmed, we would definitely have been more coordinated.
But we just weren't coordinated enough to deal with a backline.
Because I froze backline.
And I froze every backline people that came.
Not everyone, but I tried my best to freeze as many of the people that were trying to get us in the backline.
And also I called it out multiple times.
But like, you know, there was just nothing I could do.
Other than that.
Yeah, I was just like, I called it out.
I called it out and I froze them.
It's not just up to me after that.
So it's more so of just like, by the way, I'm going to be playing ranked.
I'm going to be playing ranked just to at least feel something.
So I'll just do one.
Fuck yeah, I could lose.
I could be out of top 500.
I'll just lose a game.
It's fine.
I think the Senna and Ulsim are all still scrimming.
So I can't really grab anybody in the Senna and Ulsim at the moment.
But we need some form of therapy at the moment.
We need...
We need some form...
I don't mind losing a rank.
I already lost...
Trifor only solos.
He doesn't duo anymore.
Also, I think he's...
I think he's just like, he could be doom queuing too.
He could might as well be doom queuing as well.
I don't see him.
No,
I don't want to play quick play.
I just want to doom queue.
I only wanted to be top 500 before the tournament just so I could feel happy about something.
Before the tournament.
Yeah, it's fine.
It's alright though.
It's alright.
I just want to... I just knew going in it was going to be fine.
I'm trying not to take stuff like this too seriously too.
Especially when it's a creator cup, I was like, don't take it as seriously.
I mean, I did stay playing while there was a fucking fire alarm going on.
So I was just like, it's okay.
Wait, what the... Why did it glow?
I'm sad.
I'm sad that the Loki costume isn't out yet.
That was going to be the first thing I spend money on.
I didn't like any costumes other than... I think President Loki is actually like...
President Loki was like the one costume I actually liked.
Thank God it was a drill.
Thank God.
Yeah, mentally support wise.
Alright.
We go in.
If we lose, it's okay.
I'm already used to it.
I'm ready.
What's another... What's OA?
You know?
We're Doom queuing right now.
What's wrong with an OA, you know?
Oh no, I was banned Namor.
My go-to banline is Namor Groot.
I fucking hate... You guys can swear at me.
I don't care.
I don't care about Hela.
Fuck, okay.
I guess I don't want to play against Hela.
I personally just do not want to play against Namor.
Whoops, sorry.
Oh.
We'll ban Hela next.
I don't mind.
We can ban Hela.
They banned Groot, so that's fine.
I've never... That's my go-to banline.
I always just ban Namor Groot because Namor is such a clutch character.
Hela I'm not that scared of versus Namor Groot because Hela is just like one person.
But Namor Groot is like just fucking...
Cancer.
Sorry, I'm going.
Also, if you guys want to know who's on streamer mode, you can literally go look here.
I figured this out.
If you're on streamer mode, you can see who's on your team by just looking up here.
I don't know.
Maybe we have a Spider-Man player.
I'm looking.
I don't know any of these people.
That's like a little hack.
That I found out.
What's the point of streamer mode?
The enemy team can't see what you are.
That's the point.
It's more about the enemy team.
But I get to see who's on my team, which is fine.
I just want to know who's on my team.
Which is okay.
Toki, it's a feature.
I don't think that was supposed to be intentional.
I don't think you're supposed to know who's on your team.
Yeah, the reason why I was like...
Namor is way too easy to play.
Because he's just way too good for how easy his util is.
I mean, Bucky is really good too.
But only when you're in higher ELO.
I feel like.
See?
Look at that.
Go, Bucky, go!
Yay!
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, I want to back out a little bit.
No, goodbye.
Okay, people were a little too aggressive there.
I should have said something.
People were a little too aggressive.
Woah!
Oh.
You're topping off?
Thank you.
I have a Starlord behind.
Any help?
Oh.
I'm really low.
I don't have vault for this.
Oh!
No!
Uh, let's see.
Oh wait, if you want mag back, I can swap.
Sorry.
No, it's good.
It's good.
Okay.
I'll stay.
Oh, I can ult first.
Melting.
I'm moving up.
4, 3, 2, 1.
I'm going to use my ult for Starlord ult.
Uh, mag for Starlord.
There's, uh, magic on us.
Magic can die in the back.
1 HP.
I'm reloading.
Here, Adam flanking top right on our BP.
Oh, I don't have ult yet.
I can bubble you in 3 seconds.
You'll be fine.
Oh my god!
He's behind us.
Mag low!
They wasted that.
They're rezzing behind us.
Yeah, they're rezzing here.
Ult first range.
Help our back up again.
Oh, shit.
Magic on me.
Magic low.
She's dead.
Mag half.
Mag can die.
I'm fucking mag.
Starlord half.
Starlord... oh.
He has one more jump.
He has Starlord ult here.
Yeah, I'll hold for it this time.
We have to, like, melt him though because mine doesn't last as long.
Help first range.
I can't get to you, Bucky.
I'll ult it.
Just kill him.
He got bubble.
Nice.
No more ults.
They can both cocoon.
2, 1, 0.
We should walk them.
They canceled cocoon.
Magic is in.
They are full now.
They used link.
Kite back.
We need help.
I'm backing out.
Starlord behind us.
Starlord behind.
We got mag.
Mag half.
I have bubble.
I have magic on me.
I might be dead.
I'm dead.
Magic 1.
You have no supports.
I'm coming back.
I can try to touch.
I have ult.
Did you use both DPS ults?
They're good.
We're going to be close to mantis.
3, 2, 1.
Backing out.
I froze mag.
I hear someone up here.
It's starlord, right?
Starlord, Resi.
It's close left in the bottom left room.
Look at the mantis if you can.
Help our tanks.
We have magic on point.
They have no heals.
They only have items.
Actually, yeah, they're all dead.
They have one more touch.
Can you try to counter portal?
Do you know how to do it?
Okay, nice.
They're not portaling.
They're just walking.
Magic's coming in.
Use mantis to touch.
She can die.
She's kind of running in.
They're going to have invisible when ult after this turn.
Magic on me.
I froze her.
I don't have bubble.
No bubble.
Nice.
If we can live for 10, I have...
Oh, I got magicked.
That's unlucky.
That's unlucky that magic got me.
They used everything.
They're running triple support.
Okay.
They're going to have like 50% Adam.
We're up one for now.
I'm asleep.
BORN AGAIN!
To the right side.
Right room.
I don't think we should push that.
Okay.
They used soulbond already.
They're going to be close to mantis.
They have magical here.
I don't have my ult for starlord yet.
We got a hook.
We have to kite this.
We kind of need to save for starlord ult.
Yeah, I'm saving mine.
Actually, I'm almost there.
I might have it.
Can you top me off real quick?
Okay, I have.
I have.
I'll use ult starlord.
I'll ult first.
He's flanking starlord top left.
I got it.
They used soulbond.
4, 3, 2, 1.
I'm on my ult.
This is the last fight.
Last fight.
I froze mag.
I'm on mantis ult.
Mag on point.
Mag half.
We're killing their entire backline.
There's only one good magic player.
Two good magic players.
In high elo.
In one above all.
It's Azula.
But the thing is, she only plays magic.
So are you target banned?
Do you want to go mag?
It's like good into the starlord matchup.
If you target ban Azula, she can play other characters.
But obviously, it's sort of a nerf on their team if she's not on magic.
If she's put on any other character, it's like we rather her be on magic.
I might be just very unlucky whenever I have her.
But whenever I have her and magic is banned, I'm yet to win with her when she can't play magic.
And the other one is Ry.
Ry is known as the best pro magic player.
Pro player that's a magic player.
There's only two good magic players that I know in this elo.
And Ry is like the best pro player that plays magic.
Azula is the best rank grinder magic player.
They are.
She was streamer mode.
You just can't see it.
You can't see it when... it's streamer mode until like 50% of the game.
I'm going to put us on this high ground with Aluna.
Maybe we can one shot her.
Right in front of us.
She dropped into arcade.
I'm going to follow her.
Aluna is like full 1 HP.
I can try to chase.
All their healers are in this corner.
I'm 1 HP.
And you have no supports.
I'm kind of a bad support, I bet.
Wait,
Panther, can you peek me?
Okay, I got you.
I just got here.
How's everything going?
I'm coping by playing rank right now.
That's sort of how I'm going.
I might need heals.
Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky, Bucky one!
He got bubbled.
We're up in healer.
Look at their Bucky on point.
Oh, shit.
I can't see you, you're in invis.
I'm up.
Oh, we have Loki.
Kill the Bucky, kill the Bucky.
Oh my god, they're... No!
I got subbed.
Oh my god, mag Bucky ulted.
You don't have Luna heals.
I come back, we will... Oh no, nevermind, we don't need it.
Adam's gonna ult, I'll try to stun him out of it.
I'm coming back, we will...
Mag?
Two, one, zero.
I can't, I'm sorry.
I can't see you, Panther.
They're not portaling.
Nice.
Did they use Luna ult there?
No, he has Luna ult.
Okay, they're probably close to him just then.
Did they use Adam?
No, he died before he could.
Okay, so he still has it.
I'm pushing cart.
We got a huge hook.
Loki's healing, I'm pushing cart.
Okay.
You guys should swap.
Mag, look.
Look to bubble your Tracer.
Do you have bubble?
Oh, bubble me now, bubble me now.
As soon as you can see me.
Scott, ult him in the back.
Nice heal, nice heal.
How long till it ends?
We don't need yet, we don't need yet.
We're doing this, they're gonna rez that probably.
I'm pushing for it.
Adam, Adam, Adam in here, Adam in here.
Oh, in the room?
Okay.
Oh, sorry, I thought I was in.
Kill the Mag, kill the Mag.
That was my bad.
Sorry, that was my bad.
Bad call from me.
That's okay, that's okay.
I mean, I don't think we're making it up anyways.
They used Luna, Adam, Starlord, Mag, Bucky, Invis.
They're gonna be close to Invis first.
Actually, they probably have Mag.
I'm gonna ask for bubble again when I go for ult.
Because they can push me away.
Alright.
He's hooking Karen.
Let's drop main, this building is kind of hard.
We're back, Bucky.
Oh, shit.
We have Immo just.
We kind of can't tower down here right now.
We have no DPS.
Hey, Bucky can ult first.
He's hooking Karen.
He missed.
Okay, I'm looking for ult.
Actually, no I'm not.
I don't want to.
I hear someone to my left.
I don't know who.
Starlord.
Nice.
Okay, they matched.
Ours lasts a little longer.
I'm gonna look for a strange ult to get out of this.
There's a mag above us.
He's one.
He's low.
He's still low.
He's getting rezzed, Karen.
Three people got rezzed.
I have ult on that.
I got him.
Kill the Starlord if you can.
Starlord's low.
Starlord's still low.
Do you have bubble right now?
Bubble your strange right now if you have it.
Killed one healing.
I'm blocking heals with Bucky.
Kill the Bucky.
I'm blocking heals with him.
Do you have bubble?
No.
That might not be optimal.
That's unlucky.
We just didn't have bubble.
They went triple support, so there was nothing we could do.
It was a good fight, though.
It was actually a good game.
I like that the game was decent.
Yeah, it was a good game.
It was just unlucky that they went triple support, so they just had more sustainability there.
That's fine.
Yeah, actually, the team was decent.
We had a decent team.
And both...
Oh shit, what time is it?
Okay, I was gonna say...
Yeah, like, that was actually a really good game.
Like, I actually enjoyed that game.
No.
It's not...
It's not food time.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're still scrimming.
They don't end until 30 minutes, so I'll just wait.
I'll just keep playing until then.
But the games were actually pretty decent.
Tournament's over.
Okay, tournament is over.
I play ranked.
I made a bad call about the rez there, but I don't think it would have mattered anyway.
I thought he was below.
No, Adam's good.
Adam's good if he has triple support.
You go...
The thing is, they had Adam Mantis.
They had Adam...
Adam Starlord, so they had double rez.
So I had to...
I thought it was bottom because he did bottom last time, but he, like, actually juked it and everything.
I don't know.
I don't know if I called the correct...
The correct rez.
Yeah, it was hard to kill everything.
Like, I used my Luna ult when I had...
Well, like, basically I had to use it during the Bucky ult and everything.
I mean, if I really want to cheese it, I just remember their banner.
This is how people do.
And they know they have a one trick.
If I say level 55...
Level 55...
Because Azula is always on streamer mode because she doesn't want to get her magic ban.
This is what people do in higher elo.
They recognize their banner, and then they recognize the level 55, and then they just target banner.
That's all the pro...
What all the high elo pro players do.
They...
Like, it's crazy.
Apparently, a lot of pro players, they have a list.
They write down.
They like...
After, like, during ranked games, they actually, like, write down, like, what their banners are.
And what level they are.
So, like, they can target ban them to specifically make the games easier for themselves.
Because, like, I know this.
Because while I was playing with some of them, they'd be like, let me look at my list.
They, like, actually, like, write down, like, who they're playing.
Like, if they know they're playing against a one trick.
So, if I see...
Level...
Oh, wait.
Wait, there's another level 55.
Oh, we have the magic player on my team.
The magic player is on my team now.
There you go.
Level 55, magic banner.
I was like, wait, there's two magic banners.
Oh, no.
This better be Jesse.
Jesse is the only Jeff I trust.
About Namor group.
God, I hope they don't target ban my magic player.
Oh, my God.
I hope they don't fucking remember the level and the banner.
Oh, we're doing Adam?
Okay.
Alright.
Yay, Namor.
Yay, get him out.
Get him out.
Get him out of there.
Leave.
Leave my game.
I have not...
Every time I play with...
Every time I...
Every time I've like...
Had a game where Namor and group passes through, I've never won.
That any team would just somehow have a better Namor group player.
I'm gonna try Jeff.
Are you gonna do flank Jeff or like front line?
Probably front line.
Okay.
Because I can't really flank.
Yeah, I was thinking about that.
Because if we're gonna flank, we need a triple support.
I'm not gonna play this.
My bad.
Oh, thank God.
Thank...
Wait, is this Jesse?
Wait.
No, it's not Jesse.
I don't...
I don't trust this Jeff.
The only Jeff I trust is Jesse.
He's the only good Jeff player that I know.
Thank fucking God.
I was like...
I tried to be nice on...
I tried to be nice.
So like, you know...
I don't wanna piss off OneTrix.
They hold my ELO hostage.
I don't want my ELO to be held hostage.
Alright.
Let's go!
This might be a long stream because I feel very ranky today.
I hear someone to my right.
Hella?
Hella behind us?
Hella's still behind.
Aww.
I couldn't do anything.
Oh no, I'm getting PTSD.
I'm getting PTSD now.
Alright, it's Jeff time.
Oh no, not the flank PTSD.
I just think for Marvel Rivals...
It's literally the only game I can stream for super long hours and I would not get tired.
That's how much I enjoy this game.
And also, I have a problem.
Oh shit.
Jesus Christ.
I was trying to have a fucking conversation.
Think it's one.
Yes.
Fuck me.
Oh my god.
Everything is okay for now.
I don't have ult yet.
I'm 94.
Oh, I'm 98.
Aww, that's so unlucky.
That's so unlucky there.
I didn't get my ult in time.
That's fine.
It was just unlucky.
We have one tank, they have two, so they build ult faster.
Like, what can I do?
Yummy, yummy.
Sad yummy, yummy.
Aww.
I don't know where the hell is.
I should have been more aware of my surroundings there.
Alright.
Hell is behind us.
I'm staying on point.
Oh, I need triple support.
Definitely need triple support.
Aww, it's so rough.
Oh, I need heals.
Thank you.
The thing is coming.
He has ult soon.
The thing has ult.
He's looking for it.
Oh no.
The hell is on me?
Aww, please.
Somebody kill the hell out.
Why can't they have the thing?
And get away with it, but I have the thing.
And like, we're trying.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, not again.
Not again.
Please, I don't want to get clobbered.
Oh man.
I think we might need triple support.
Alright.
Get in here, Jeff.
It's you and me.
Get in.
Aww, goodbye, Jeff.
Goodbye.
I don't think he had it.
Oh, you're right.
It's time to get the tired eyes ready.
I think we definitely need triple support.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, I was gonna say.
I don't know if I can...
I don't know if I can do this with one defensive ult.
I was like, I don't know, man.
One defensive ult is like...
It's a little too much for me.
It's a little...
It's a little a lot.
Just, you know, it's a lot.
And then, you know, the Hella was just going pew pew.
And I was like, Hella bye.
Am I the only support player in this game?
Other than the shark player?
Oh.
Wait, why is he stopping?
Why are you not walking?
Where are we going?
Oh, no one put this on.
Frozen?
Try not to.
Can I...
Oh, god.
Goodbye, Bucky.
You poor man.
Oh, my god.
Oh, it's... Of course, it's moving.
Oh, you poor man.
Oh, we can't see you.
Alright.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm trying my best to...
Make sure everybody is getting the heals they need.
It hits me behind the watch, bullshit.
I was around the fucking corner.
Oh, my god.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
I kill first.
How is that possible?
Three, two, one.
Oh, my god.
That...
Okay.
At least I froze him.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Someone's child is fucking saying stuff.
Thing is low.
Oh, my god.
We did it.
We capped.
Okay, that fucking...
That fucking... All behind was fucked up.
That was actually...
That was actually so fucked up.
Bro, this guy... Take care of your child, please.
Take care of your child.
Oh, no.
I am not optimistic right now.
We don't see you for heals.
Nice.
He has will-o.
I'm... There's a hell up top.
High ground.
I can't peek.
There's still a hell of high ground.
I'm not... I'm not peeking anymore.
Nice.
Okay.
I'll try to ult first.
You're walking for it?
No shit.
I'm ulting this.
I'm damage boosting you.
One.
Three can clone me.
Come on.
I have no passive.
Nice.
Nice shot.
Oh, they all got off.
They all got off the point.
Thank God.
Thank God there is a guide.
There is a fucking guide.
I believe now.
Oh.
Oh, thank God.
And the only skin I like for supports is President Loki.
Every other skin fucking sucks.
I don't... You can't change my mind.
I think every other skin, the supports are not that great.
That's what I'm saying.
They've been playing magic since season... since beta.
So, like, this person better be a really fucking good magic player.
And they are.
Having the wrong opinion is fine.
I like it.
I like it, personally.
Not a huge fan.
Guys, you didn't see me whiff like three fucking shots on them.
You didn't see that, guys.
Hahaha.
Oh, no.
I guess we leave.
Hahaha.
Reload.
That's fine.
I didn't miss these, though.
What?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
There's a...
There's a heli to our left.
I got it.
Pushing up.
Oh.
That's fine.
Oh, please, copy!
Oh, thank God!
I feel so safe!
Mag half.
Oh, that sucks.
That actually sucks.
Oh, that really sucks.
I have to reload.
Oh, that's fine.
Our Punisher was just not having a good day, guys.
Our...
Hahaha.
You know, our Punisher...
He's at a...
He may or may not be on a negative KDA at the moment.
And that is fine!
That is okay!
Mr. Splashgun is not having it.
That's okay.
That's okay!
Okay, two, one.
Oh, this is a little scary, though.
He's frozen.
The one time I peeked!
I was looking at self-heal.
Shift.
It's okay, guys.
The game is very good.
I now have my first avoid of the day.
Hahaha.
I don't think Splashgun...
was doing it for today.
I...
Hahaha.
I don't think Splashgun really knew what he was doing.
Okay, wait.
Actually...
I mean...
I need to feel something so I play ranked, guys.
I just...
I need to feel something.
Hahaha.
Alright, don't worry.
I got you, guys.
This is how I...
It's time for how I truly feel today.
It's time.
There we go.
It's time for how I truly feel.
I don't know, I think I was doing alright.
I was doing alright.
I mean, like, what can I do?
I'm fucking Luna.
Hahaha.
This is the only way I feel joy.
Playing ranked is what will give me happiness.
Hahaha.
I mean, the games are good, though.
I have to admit.
I...
Uh...
The games are, like...
Are good.
I'm enjoying the games.
Because it's, like, higher elo.
So, like, I can...
It's just, you know...
It feels much...
Definitely feels...
It's, like, much more coordinated than what I'm more used to.
Yeah.
So, like, it's more high...
It's, like...
Obviously, it's, like...
People are, like, higher skilled.
So, like...
Uh...
I feel, like...
I do enjoy...
Like...
Even if I lose...
I enjoy the quality of the games more.
Uh...
A little bit more...
A little bit more laid back.
Well...
I don't care right now about, like...
I just want good quality.
Like, I want to have, like, a good quality game where it feels close.
Because...
Um...
Like, it's...
I just want, like, close games type deal.
Oh, I have the magic player again.
I think I'm just gonna queue into the same...
Oh, no.
Please!
No!
How do I
have...
That's crazy.
Maybe today is just very unlucky.
Maybe it's just a very unlucky day today.
No, I have two...
Wait, it's...
Oh, my God.
We don't know what we want to ban.
We don't know what we want to fucking ban.
Look at these 25, 25, 20...
Alright, let's go gambling.
Okay, they ban Neymar.
Thank fucking God.
Okay, it can't all be doom queuing, guys.
It's not...
It can't all just be doom queue.
Some of these games are just what it is.
Fuck yeah, let's just ban Starlord.
I don't mind.
I...
I don't know how I feel about my team.
Okay.
Jeff, Chucky, Le...
I have no idea who these people are.
To be fair, I play at night usually.
So, I don't know the morning hour people.
I don't know the morning hour...
The morning hour players.
Or the afternoon players.
Never seen them before in my life.
Okay.
Woah.
Alright.
This is looking optimistic.
Is this Karth again?
No.
Yeah, it is.
It's domination.
Um...
This is fine.
I'll put it on the strange.
The day shift people.
I always thought I missed the Korean players.
The Korean players would bring me more joy.
I miss them.
I'm in streamer mode.
I have streamer mode on because I don't like people knowing.
It's actually been really helpful.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is going on?
Where's our...
We have one tank?
Where's our other tank?
Oh, we do have one tank.
I didn't even realize.
Oh my god.
I'll ult first.
Push up with this?
It's back here.
Adam's low.
Adam half.
Woah.
Invis low.
Or close, sorry.
You only have one heal.
Trying to heal you.
Oh, I'm trying my best.
We're trying.
There's an Adam behind you guys.
Adam behind.
Oh, nice.
He's dead.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh my god.
I'm so stressed out.
I'm so stressed out right now.
What the fuck is going...
I didn't reload.
Okay, okay.
Door to the left.
Door on me.
Three,
two, one.
Backing out.
I'm on...
I got push off point.
We're ulted.
We'll just wait.
It'll be fine.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ, what the fuck is going on?
What is going on?
What is going on right now?
Oh my god, thank god.
We have rez here.
Rez, rez, rez up here.
Adam is right here.
Top, top, top.
Alright.
Did he use those rez though?
He didn't, yeah.
Portal.
I have ult.
I'm gonna ult this.
Actually, we don't need it yet.
Ulting now.
Four, three, two, one.
I froze somebody.
Door one, door one.
Oh no, this is the last fight.
Touch, touch, touch, touch, touch, touch.
No.
I need second tank, I can't.
Don't worry, it's just constant pushing.
I don't know, I think one of our supports should go fucking Bucky.
I can play second tank, but...
I don't know, bro.
We're forcing Rocket and Bucky is undamaged.
Like, someone needs to play Bucky, bro.
Like, you just held S from point for some reason and let them cap for free.
Can you tank, Ratkin?
Or no?
Oh no.
Why can't...
Why can't they Bucky?
Why can't they walk forward?
This is a curse.
None of them walk forward.
It's not a problem, I'm just gonna constantly push by tower and then you have no front line.
We didn't... I don't understand why we don't walk forward.
At least it's not me.
I think I'm doing pretty alright.
What the fuck?
It's not me at least, you know?
At one point it's me though.
At one point.
I might have to dodge this Q though.
Try it.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
At one point it's me.
I think he's a one trick, isn't he?
I don't know.
We just gotta play around the one trick.
Let it go.
Add him to the right, add him by himself.
Oh my god, I got you.
Oh, I'm walking forward.
Nice, there's a...
I don't think I live.
Oh shit, hello.
I was like, hello.
There's a Thor on supports.
Guys, at one point is it me?
Guys, at one point.
Should I say maybe it's me?
Guys, at one point is it me, guys?
I can't tell.
Or is it because of Raccoon?
Is it because of Raccoon?
Or is it because of me?
At what point is it?
I can't tell anymore.
I can't.
I am...
There's a Thor on me.
I don't have a...
I'm 97.
97.
At what point is it me?
No, no, this is my shield.
Okay.
I can't tell.
Goodbye.
It's not?
Okay, good.
Alright, it's not my fault.
That's good.
Don't worry, chat will let me know.
Thank you guys.
I'm glad.
I'm glad chat is there for me.
It's not me.
That's good to know.
Oh, thank god.
It's not me.
Thank fucking god.
I was curious, you know?
I'm like, at what point if it is me?
Yay, it's not me.
Thank god.
It's not me.
Let's go.
I shall break the streak someday.
How does a rocket have ATK healing?
That's actually very impressive for a rocket.
That is incredible.
You know what?
I have the most heals.
I'll take this.
At last, it was.
I'm gonna fucking walk my dog.
Walking.
Get ready for a long day.
It's not me.
Thank god.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I am back.
I am back, guys.
You know, at least Jokey is having a good day.
Because like, while I was taking him on a walk...
We bumped into a...
We were waiting at the crossroads.
And like, there was a bunch of nurses.
A pretty lady nurses.
While we were waiting for the...
The crossroads.
And then, you know, they all loved him.
And then they're like, aw, you're so cute.
And you're like, what guy?
And then obviously he was getting...
He was getting surrounded by all these beautiful nurses.
And then he's...
They're all like petting him.
And it was like, Jokey.
Aw, Jokey, Jokey.
And then, at least somebody's having a good day.
At least one Jokey is having a great day.
You know, that's all that matters.
At least one of us is going through a good day.
Oh my god.
Okay, let me just...
Let me just tell...
Okay, let me call real quick.
Let me call real quick.
Hello, I am 10-0 right now.
And like, it's not looking good for me.
So...
At one point, if we lose this next one, then I will find out that I might be the problem.
And I hope by you playing with me, I don't curse your team.
Oh sorry, I'm 0-10.
Sorry, I forgot when you're losing, your side is the 0.
Sorry, I'm 0-10.
By the way, I hope that I do not give you all my bad luck and then Sentinels is gonna lose.
I hope that's not the case.
No, no, it's not gonna happen.
But if Sentinels does lose to 100 Thieves today, you can blame me.
I've cursed your team.
Alright, I'm gonna get a call now and talk to my chat now.
Good luck out there.
I'll try to do some good comms.
All I'm saying is if somehow Sentinels lose, it's because I touched the...
Okay, that sounded very bad.
It's because my bad luck has spread.
It's like a fucking virus.
It's like a pandemic.
Guys, I know I hate to say this.
I know it's fucking crazy.
But not every day you can win, guys.
I can't win every day, guys.
Today is one of those days where sadly, I know it's fucking crazy.
But like, you just can't win.
Not every day you can win in life.
Today is one of those days.
It's just one of those days.
I just need one win.
One win!
Okay.
Alright.
Namor.
I swear to God, if I see a Namor fucking gets through.
I swear to fucking God.
I don't even know if Gomez has streamer mode on.
Oh my God.
I hope he puts streamer mode on.
I swear to God, if Starlord... Oh, thank God.
If Starlord is the second ban, I swear to fucking God.
I'm just gonna be put on streamer mode right now.
I am not here to get targeted.
When you're grouped up with someone, you don't see it.
In your group, you don't know if they're in streamer mode or not.
Wait, we're batting Adam?
Are we actually batting Adam?
I hope I win the 20%.
I don't care.
Yay!
I think they're gonna yell at me now.
And before they yell at me.
I'm so ready for them to yell at me for winning the 20%.
There goes my luck.
We're so gonna get yelled at now.
We're so gonna get yelled at.
It is what it is.
Yipee!
There goes my luck.
I shouldn't talk in this game.
I already caused the first disruption.
I am not talking in this game now.
I am not.
I'm scared.
I'm not talking in this game.
I don't think they're happy that I won the 20% chat.
Great.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Mantis Luna.
We do not have enough heals here.
That's for sure.
Surely they went out ahead.
You know, I've already encountered so many losses.
Like, I'm... anything would be a pleasant surprise.
I'll be pleasantly surprised with whatever results we get.
You're alone, by the way.
I'd be pleasantly surprised.
Oh my god.
Alone.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm almost out of health.
You guys win.
Okay.
Okay, I'll only start talking.
There's a Psylocke up top.
I'm going to stand top right.
I'm standing invis.
Invis dies.
Oh no, I talked.
They know I...
They know now.
There's a Psylocke behind me.
Psylocke behind me, please.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
I got Psylocked.
It's fine.
There was nothing I could do.
The Psylocke chose me to die and I was like, okay.
I was like, that's my life now.
That's my life.
Psylocke is a cheater.
No, he's not.
Nah.
Yeah, he is.
You know, because DinaeQ is...
Yeah, DinaeQ is with this guy all the time.
I think he's actually cheating.
Yeah, he is.
Really?
Oh, that's interesting.
He'll be ready to damage boost me.
That's what I call it.
Let's go.
Can you damage boost me?
Yeah, damage boost me, damage boost me.
I got two, I got two.
It's all on me, by the way.
Nah, nah, it's all on me.
Hey, did your team win, Andrew?
We won four games out of seven.
Bro, all seven games have been almost banned, by the way.
I didn't play.
Yes.
Nice shield, dude.
Which?
You, bro.
I'm not in this.
Yeah, I know.
I need heals.
I got cooked.
Nice.
Can we go with Mantis ult?
Like, hard deep.
Yeah, I can go whenever.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
I'm grappling in three, two, one.
Did you have bubble?
I'm okay.
Luna dies.
These guys just melt me in one second.
I need reload, I need reload.
I don't know, I probably might die whenever I come in, I'm sorry.
First range.
I have a Psylocke ult.
I mean...
You should only have Scarlet and ult, right?
And I guess Invis ult.
I think I have...
Bust support.
Yeah.
I'm summoning Bust support.
Yeah, bro.
Bro, I'm gonna fucking lose my mind.
I mean, they have Scarlet, so...
I can look for summon fire, but...
I love you.
I'm going in three, two, one, summoning Bust support.
Bust support.
I have to help this.
Damage boosting, damage boosting.
I'm gonna Invis, I'm gonna Invis.
We're gonna Invis ult.
I'm gonna summon ult.
Wait, I'm summoning Bust support.
I'm on Luna.
Oh my god.
I cannot survive.
Mito!
Oh my god, I was so close.
I was so close.
I thought I was fucked up.
What was that?
I'm gonna summon backline and go now.
Bust support.
I don't have grapple to get up.
I'm guessing to walk.
There's someone behind me, there's someone.
Oh.
I'm always just getting sidelocked.
Big boom.
The hard targeting.
That's interesting, because Blessed has three different accounts in top 500.
And if he is actually a hacker, that is very interesting.
Because I know who he plays with.
I'm going in three, two, one.
He's one.
Sorry, can't keep you up.
No!
So they're calling him out as a hack.
I know who exactly...
I don't know.
Nobody knows who he is, by the way.
Nobody knows.
We've asked pro players around who he is.
But no one knows who he is.
We just know he's a...
Yeah, I was in here.
I can ult first.
If I survive my slam for longer than one second.
Can we match it with Luna, please?
Yeah, oh.
I can, I can.
Oh.
Big boom.
Oh, yeah.
I couldn't.
I got strangled, dude.
Nah, it's fine, it's fine.
It's still winnable.
Probably just gonna solo the Luna.
You don't have heals.
Don't, don't do this.
I can't, she's running.
I already saw one fight.
They used...
Solo, solo.
You got solo.
Okay, I don't have any shields, though.
Yeah, yeah, you can...
I'm soloing backline now.
Mag dies, mag dies, mag dies.
Nice.
I can slam backline in 3, 2, 1.
Probably just gonna solo this.
I can't die.
Probably just die instantly.
I can't.
I actually can't.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
They have Scarlet, that's why.
I'm gonna have to use it.
I'm TPing for you guys.
Somebody died.
I don't have it, I don't have it anymore.
Mag, mag got grappled, dude.
Mag won, mag won!
Kill it.
One, one.
Oh.
We should have Scarlet all here.
Invis one, invis one!
Luna, luna, luna behind!
Nice, nice.
Nice.
Kog'Maw's here, mic's not working.
I'll drool.
I'll try to drool.
Go, mag, go, go, go.
What the fuck?
Go, mag, go, go.
Shut up, DRB.
Help him.
Oh!
He's mid behind review!
Damn.
I never stop.
Bro, you keep saying they have Scarlet, but Scarlet does tickle damage, no?
But her E, it's like...
Yeah, but no.
Yeah, yeah, no.
Wait, so what's...
What's leading you then?
I don't know, bro.
Maybe the sword, bro?
I don't fucking know.
Maybe it's just a mag, punching you.
Maybe it's just a mag.
Maybe it's just skill death.
I think it's the Psylocke.
She always shoots at you.
She never goes...
Yeah, I think she's just pretty much spamming you, bro.
Honestly.
I think she thinks so.
Why?
Bro, like...
Maybe it's Linkzr's ult.
Yeah, like...
Oh, really?
Even Sinatraa said it.
Like, the guy...
I don't know.
Is this a full...
Is this an EU stack?
I'm pretty sure.
It's a full European stack.
And it's just me and Gomez.
The NA.
In NA.
Yeah, they're TPing.
They're TPing, bye.
I'm gonna somebody block out.
I don't wanna fucking die here.
They won't look out.
They won't.
What the fuck is...
I didn't turn inside then, but I'm gonna fucking die.
I'm gonna bubble you up.
You ready?
Yeah, just one sec.
Oh my god.
Like, you have to, like, do something.
But I can't.
TP, I touch.
Pots.
Alright.
I can touch last second, which hurts.
I think it's really useless, though.
No, no, try it.
He's doing it, he's doing it.
I'm fucking insta-dead, bye bye.
Winable, winable, winable, winable.
It's so winnable.
I think I should just go Mantis.
No.
Bro, I don't fucking know how to play.
Andrew, just play Menno.
I'm gonna set backline in three.
Come on, setting everyone?
Big time.
I don't think I can get all the time.
You can maybe get it.
I'm just AFK in front right now, they're not capping.
Yeah, but I can't, the tanks are blocking us.
I got it, I got it.
I'm pushing up.
You ready, you ready?
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah.
Now.
No, is that strange?
Yeah, who said it was a bad idea?
Who said that?
Yeah, Andrew.
Andrew!
Damn,
Andrew.
I can't believe you said it was a bad idea.
Zero out of ten, RageVader.
Zero out of ten.
Why do you think I'm playing Rink?
I want to win at something.
I'm gonna set backline.
I got an invis, I got an invis.
Finally, I got someone.
Oh, no.
Okay.
We're missing Bucky, but it's fine.
They only have Luna heals.
I'm summoning Luna right now.
We can't melee you from here.
I got her, I got her, I got her.
Come back DRP you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're by yourself.
We're trying to catch you up.
Yeah, DRP on Train is crazy, though.
I see.
That is crazy.
Can we just kill the fucking...
There's a Mag that's by himself.
I'm just landing backline, guys.
You guys can try to kill the tanks.
Oh, Mag low, Mag low.
I'm here.
They might TP.
We can get...
If I'm Luna ult here, if I'm Luna ult...
Yeah, I'm 70%, I'm 70%.
90.
90, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
I'll be back in action soon.
I can use DRP, but...
I know.
No, no, wait, wait.
Bring top right again.
He's gonna get booped, bro.
Let's like...
Yeah, I know.
We're fighting on point.
Oh, my god.
I'm coming in!
Not ult, Luna.
Yeah, I got it, I'm running.
I mean, you can try to do it, but...
I don't know where that is.
I'm fine, I'm okay, I'm okay.
We can do it, bro.
They're all high ground, they're all high ground.
He's gonna solo the Luna.
3, 2, 1.
I can't dodge, I'm okay.
I froze Jhin.
I'm almost back, I'm almost back.
I can try...
After Luna, I was like, I'm gonna just...
Yeah, I'm almost back.
Wait, Kim.
We almost have...
We almost have invis-ult.
Come on, Desi, bro.
You're on top of me, Desi.
Desi, come on, bro.
I can dodge, I can dodge.
Nice, Kim.
Nice!
I'm back.
We're gonna be on point, we're gonna be on point, we're gonna be on point.
Jhin, Jhin, Jhin, Jhin, Jhin.
He's alone, he's alone, he's alone.
I'm dodging, I'm dodging, I'm dodging.
I got you guys, I got you guys.
It's just...
It's strange, it's strange.
Let's go!
Wait, now it's 1-10.
Let's go.
Thanks for the 1-10, Andrew.
Oh, finally.
We did it!
1-10!
Yes!
All we needed was Europeans.
We just needed Europeans on our team.
That's it!
Oh my god!
We just...
We just needed...
We just needed Europeans.
The curse is broken.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
We did it.
We did it, guys.
The EU buff succeeded.
Oh my god, the EU buff.
Let's go!
That's all we needed.
Oh my god.
We did it.
That was not the problem!
Let's go!
Not the problem!
That's all I ever wanted.
It was never my fault, guys.
It was never my fault.
It was the NA team.
No, no, no, no, no.
It was not, guys.
It was not NA.
It was just that we had EU players with hands, guys.
We just had players who had hands.
And that's all that matters.
You were never the problem.
Oh my god.
They actually had hands!
We were there, everybody.
We were fucking there.
For a great moment in life.
Oh my god.
It's actually crazy.
I can't believe they actually had hands, guys.
Oh my god.
We take those!
We take those.
Oh my god.
Damn.
We were there, guys.
We were fucking there.
That's crazy.
I'm just happy in life.
You know what?
Now I'm happy again.
Now I can feel joy again.
Now I...
Yippee!
Who's Desley?
Is Desley the...
Oh my god.
Who the fuck is Desley?
I'm adding you.
I don't know who Desley is.
But you're cool in my book.
You're cool in my book.
Okay.
Desley.
Oh my god.
Desley's a gamer.
Joy has been restored, everybody.
Joy has been restored.
I don't know...
Okay.
So, the thing about Blessed...
Let me show you guys all of his accounts.
So, the thing is...
Valentina has queued with Blessed.
That's why I was like...
I didn't think Blessed was hacking.
Because he has queued with several people that I know in the scene.
But we've asked around the pro players.
And nobody knows who he is.
Like, nobody knows who...
Other than like...
I think like...
Someone knows.
But like...
The pro players we've asked...
Has no idea who Blessed is.
So, Valentina has queued with Blessed.
And also like...
Oh my god.
We're with LG.
Okay.
We have the LG stack on our team.
No.
Tim is not number one.
It's Guru.
TimTheTatman gifted 150 subs.
So that the rank 1 guy will change his name to TimTheTatman.
I should do that.
I wanna do that.
I would be like...
I'll give you 200 subs if you do the same thing.
I'm just happy I'm not the problem.
That's really it.
Oh.
Well, it doesn't matter.
He's like...
Don't ban Groot.
Whoops.
Groot is for bums.
What do we ban then?
I don't know.
That's my usual go-to ban line.
Why is everybody banning Adam now?
Don't ban Groot.
Groot goes too.
I mean...
I could go Adam too.
Oh, okay.
I like Adam.
Adam's fun.
As a support player, I like Adam.
Is this the...
Oh, wait.
This is EU LG.
The fuck?
Why are they all here?
Where are the EU players?
This is EU LG.
I reckon...
What the fuck?
We have all the Europeans today.
But now I think they're great.
I'm so not used to it.
Can't believe Andrew was like...
You're 0-10.
I was like...
Who snitched?
Who told him?
Somebody in my chat...
Went to Andrew's chat...
And was like...
Doki's 0-10.
She needs this.
Somebody snitched on me.
That's so fucked.
I can't believe it.
Cause how else would he know?
Cause that includes my ranking too.
He fucking gave him my ranking score.
And he said 0-7.
I'd be like...
Yeah, no.
100%.
Yeah.
But the fact that he said 0-10...
Means that somebody fucking...
Fucking...
Somebody snitched.
Okay.
That's fucked, guys.
Who was it?
Who the fuck was it?
I know it's one of you guys.
I push the cart.
I am a cart pusher.
I am a passenger princess.
There's...
Dang it.
You don't see that.
You go first, Mantis.
Oh, god.
Oh, I'm...
I need help.
I'm okay.
There's a mag behind us.
There's a mag.
I think.
I have ult.
Two.
One.
No more.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus, guys.
You guys are gaming.
I have to reload.
I need heals.
I need heals here.
I froze him.
Thing is low.
Thing is so low.
We have nothing.
I got hit by it.
Starlord one.
Jesus Christ.
This is a high elo, Gabi.
This is doom queuing hours.
Oh, I got shit on.
Yeah.
Feels bad, buddy.
I have to use this.
Oh, do you have shields?
Yes.
Thing is low.
I have a Mantis with ult.
I have a match after.
I have a match.
I froze Mag.
Thing has ult here.
Thing has ult.
Mag slept.
Mag, Mag, Mag, Mag.
Mag, Mag.
Push him.
There's a Mantis to the right.
I can't get to you.
Freeze.
This is high elo.
This is definitely high elo.
Guys, this is high elo.
This is absolutely high elo, nobbies.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I thought he was going to go some other way, but he turned around.
Fucking crazy.
Oh my god.
Freak.
Actual freak.
Mantis, you can ult first.
Thing.
One.
Mag low.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Thing on point.
Thing low.
I push cart.
Thing one.
Actually one.
No link.
You guys didn't see that.
Guys, you guys did not see that.
You guys did not see that, guys.
You guys did not see that.
Don't die.
Use luna.
Okay.
I'm using.
Combo.
Three.
Two.
One.
Dead damage.
Mantis.
One.
In here.
I think in here.
Yeah.
Hold the control.
It's hard for them to hold.
I'm frozen.
Oh, I couldn't.
Oh, hey.
Hello, buddy.
Mantis to the right.
Mantis healing.
Resing in here.
Thing frozen.
Thing one.
I'm hurt.
Guys, you didn't see me miss three shots on our star lord.
You didn't see that.
Guys, you didn't.
Guys, look.
I've been through a lot, guys.
Please.
I've been.
Guys, I've been through a lot.
If you do.
If I do not see it, you do not see it.
We've been through a lot.
Guys.
We all suffered today.
Guys, please.
Please.
You do not kick a puppy that is down and like is suffering a seizure at the moment.
Guys, that's so fucked up.
This puppy has lost the use of her back legs.
It's in a vegetative state at the moment.
You do not kick that puppy.
You do not do this.
That is fucked.
Three, two, one.
Things will be okay.
Everybody plays like a pro.
I'm scared.
This is literally like a pro team on my team.
Oh my god.
This is scary.
I don't.
He's like, I feel better already.
I don't think anything can cure what I have.
It's terminal.
Unfortunately, the brain rot is terminal.
Nothing can save me.
My condolences.
No intervention can fix what I have.
Yeah, okay.
I have to reload.
Does he have soul bar?
I froze strange.
Restart or not?
Starlord behind.
Starlord behind me.
Yeah, yeah, I hear you.
Starlord one.
Starlord solo.
One body left behind you.
Oh my god.
I have to use it.
They're gonna have strange ult here.
Damage boosting.
I'm backing out now.
They still have strange ult.
Scary.
I'm a little scared of the strange ult though.
Just a little scared.
Just a teeny weeny little bit.
There it is!
What the fuck?
There it goes.
I don't know how I dodged that.
How did I dodge that?
That's crazy.
I believe.
Yeah, it's set up in a way.
Don't kill Luna.
I've frozen.
I got the lift.
4, 3, 2, 1.
I have a thing on me.
I might dagged him.
He's chasing me.
Thank you.
He's still chasing me.
Goodbye.
I'm on point.
Oh my
god.
He's still chasing me.
They hit a checkpoint.
Now might be a good time to stop them.
That's freaking wild.
Holy shit.
That's so wild.
That's freaking wild.
Just let him.
I don't have ult here.
That's fucking wild.
Holy shit.
That's a wild thing to say.
Not gonna lie.
Goodbye.
I can save you.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Bro, what's wrong with him?
Leave me alone.
Leave me the fuck alone.
Sylar to your left.
Sylar behind you guys.
Oh, he's coming over.
Leave me alone.
Oh my god.
Just leave me alone.
Please.
We can go top right.
I'm TPing.
We're TPing.
Yeah.
Someone touch?
Put it down bro.
Oh,
that's kidding.
He's a lot old.
The freakiest of the freak.
I was like, leave me alone.
I hear
someone to my left.
I've frozen.
He's one.
I don't know where it is.
Oh, you ult first?
Okay.
I have to ult that now.
3, 2, 1.
I froze one of them.
The supports are...
Last fight.
I have to reload.
He has ult, I'm pretty sure.
I don't have to be center stage.
I've frozen.
Guys,
it's not me.
It's not just me.
3, 2, 1.
Oh, it's not me guys.
Oh my god.
Not the problem.
Not the problem chat.
Oh my god.
That's all I needed.
It's not being the problem.
That's all.
Doki plus EU equals win.
I'm not the problem.
Thank god.
We figured it out.
Eco has been saved.
I'll be right back.
It's great.
I get a thousand dollars and I don't have to feel like shit.
Oh my god.
I feel great.
I got my participation award and at least I know I'm not the problem.
Rank therapy success.
Yay.
Oh my god.
I won two games in a row.
Oh my.
It's my birthday.
It's actually my birthday.
Yippee.
Woo.
Happy birthday to me.
How the fuck do I have fate on my team?
I'm like, how do I have these people in my friends list?
I don't even remember.
I don't even remember how I had fate in here.
I had the LG people guys.
Whoa.
Wait.
Okay.
I need to know.
Yeah.
See.
I had the LG.
Oh hey.
Hey.
Dad.
Did you know?
I'm not the problem.
Yeah.
I'm not the problem little guy.
I'm climbing.
Well no, I'm down again.
But like, hey.
Oh my god.
No, I know we do not message the team to let them know that guys.
No, that's a little fucked up.
You know what was fucked up?
Telling Andrew I was 0-10.
That was fucked up.
You know, you could've been like, yeah, she went 0-7.
But you had to include my rank score along the way.
Now it's 2-10.
Okay?
I'm 2-10 now.
That was the fucked up part.
You kicked a disabled puppy.
I was having a seizure on the ground.
And you slid over to Andrew's chat and was like, hey, you wanna cut this puppy's legs off too?
Might as well.
She's defenseless and fragile.
You might as well.
That's fucked up.
How is this like I taught you?
Oh my God.
You're like, cut this puppy's legs off.
She's not using it.
I was.
I was using it.
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway.
So, uh, Doki will kick the dragon once in that situation.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, back to the blessed guy.
So like, alright.
So when they were calling out blessed as a hacker.
Alright, let me show you.
Okay, I know there's like several accounts.
So blessed is also, um.
So this is blessed.
And blessed has like two other accounts in top 500.
Unless they dropped out.
They have blessed and two other.
They all have the same names.
It's basically all of them is like the tiny ass shit that they do.
So it's all like this.
So like they're calling, the EU people were calling blessed as a hacker.
But I know who blessed queues with.
So I am, I know exactly who blessed queues with.
So it's very interesting that they're calling him out as a hacker.
Because like, um.
He, I know exactly who he plays with.
And I'm like, hmm.
You know?
You're like, hmm, I see.
Alright.
I think they dropped out.
I know only myself.
I don't think I have them on the recent players list anymore.
So they might have just dropped out recently.
Um.
So that's interesting.
Uh.
But they all have, they all basically.
Oh, hey, I'm back.
Look at that.
Look at that, guys.
Guys, don't look at that.
Yay!
Guys, no.
Guys, I swear to God.
Okay.
This might look bad.
But if I put it like this.
It looks a little better.
If I, if I put it like this.
It looks a little better, guys.
Like, don't judge me.
But I can't win everyday.
Okay.
I cannot win everyday, guys.
Sadly.
It's just like that.
I just can't.
I just can't, guys.
It is impossible to win everyday.
Oh, is it?
Yeah, guys.
I was just in colorblind mode, guys.
It was just.
It was.
I swear to God.
It was just colorblind mode.
Do I even have?
What's my proficiency on there?
Uh.
Night.
I wanna have Adam Lord.
But like, I'm definitely not close to it.
I am.
Yeah.
I am not close to it.
I need like.
Uh.
I'm just trying to get it naturally.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay, guys.
We might not be the best player.
But like, we're doing our best, guys.
We are.
We are doing our best.
Oh, they're doing something in the practice range.
When is their tournament anyway?
When is Sentinels?
Alright, let me check the Sentinels fight night shit.
Where are they at?
They are.
Oh, there's one game left.
It's best to.
So like, if we manage.
We just need.
So, this is Gomez's last game.
Basically.
Cause there's two.
One of these just needs to win one more game.
And then they fight.
Um.
And then they fight Sentinels.
So this is like his last game.
Oh, please get me a game.
Please get me a game.
Come on.
Get me a game.
At least make it so that I'm back.
I'm like.
Back to where I was.
This is last game.
Alright.
And then we're back to like.
We're back to like.
Elo hell.
I guess.
This is not our.
Guys.
This is not our last game though.
It's not our last game though.
Chat.
We.
We're still here to suffer.
Is Desi the one queuing with Andrew right now?
Can't tell.
Yeah.
He's playing with Andrew.
What if I like.
Mooch into their team.
Do you need a fourth person?
Hey.
Doki Bridge.
Oh hey.
It's Helis.
What's Helis doing here?
Oh he's.
He hid in his profile.
I can't.
It's not Korean hours yet.
I can't fucking message the Koreans to play with me.
Wait.
Did Choppa add me?
Choppa didn't.
Didn't look at his friend.
No.
Choppa didn't add me back.
He didn't accept my friend request.
He was the funny one.
He was the funniest.
Who are we playing against?
Or with?
Damn.
That 128.
Goes hard.
I don't know if that's.
That is.
The magic player.
That 128 goes so hard.
Alright.
Let's see.
Who do we have?
We.
I don't know who.
Oh.
I don't like this guy.
He like.
He like shit talk to me.
So I'm like.
I'm muting him.
He called me a bad support player.
And that.
That hurt my feelings.
I don't want him to call me a bad support player in front of my stream.
I'm already going through a lot.
Guys.
I'm going through a lot already.
I don't need him to call me bad right now.
I guess I can't.
Guys.
I'm like.
I can't move my legs.
Guys.
I'm just a little puppy.
I can't let this happen.
Alright.
Wait.
Which one is the number 8?
Alright.
Here we go.
Guys.
You don't understand.
I'm not like okay at the moment.
I'm.
If it was any other day.
Where I was not.
Where I'm not 210 right now.
It would've been fine.
But if he calls me bad.
I'm gonna cry.
Okay.
I won't cry.
I'll be very very sad.
If I wasn't 210 right now.
I would've been okay if he calls me bad.
But I am.
210 right now.
Mental health has left the chat.
Guys.
Can you gas me up a little bit before he.
Can you guys gas me up before he destroys all my.
Oh shit.
Okay.
We should've queued up.
Whoops.
Sorry.
Whoopsie.
I cannot understand you.
What's wrong with your mic?
You're like talking on the water.
Alright.
Wait what?
Why are we.
Woah!
That lag spike.
Was fucking rough for me.
Azla.
Don't call me bad please.
Wait I.
You can't call me bad.
Alright I'm gonna go in.
I'm gonna go in bubble.
Yup.
3, 3, 3, 3.
No, no, no.
Oh okay.
Nevermind.
I have it now though.
You can't call me bad if he's muted.
You're right guys.
Alright let's do this.
Ready?
I don't know.
Loki 1.
Ela 1.
Can I get a point?
It's fine.
We just don't talk.
I'm going up top again.
This is okay.
It's okay.
We're so healthy.
We did it guys.
Things will be okay.
Look at that.
I can hit shots.
Things will be so healthy.
I should not break that.
But like.
I'll just do it just cause.
Uhh.
I'm ready.
Come on Malte.
Oh okay.
Nevermind.
Mantis heal first.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I have yet.
Oh my god.
He does not see me.
And that's okay.
That's okay.
He doesn't see me.
Oh my god.
Play it.
Okay.
Where?
Where is he?
Wait.
Think behind.
Please don't let him beat me up.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Come on man.
Come on.
Please.
Where?
Where is he?
I can't tell.
Where?
I didn't know where to look at.
It was very confusing guys.
It was.
That was a little weird.
Alright.
I need to hit something.
Oh, don't look at me.
Oh, that was such a good shield.
I'm 98!
Okay.
Oh, I got it.
Hello.
Oh my god.
No, not the born again.
Not the born again.
No.
Where is the born again?
I can't tell.
Oh shit, that's huge.
Yeah, fuck this clone in particular.
Yeah, fuck that one clone.
Alright.
I am not like the best.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Things are...
Things are feeling a little better right now.
You know, I think I'm sensing a pattern here.
As long as I have a European on my team...
Like, things are looking up for Doki.
I just need Europeans on my team.
I think that's...
I think that's the key.
I think that's actually the key, guys.
Oh man.
I wish the Koreans were awake.
I wish they were awake.
I miss the Korean players.
I promise Choppa I'll make him viral.
He was like, promise me you'll make me go viral.
And I was like, I promise.
Donkey Kong.
And I was like, I promise I'll make you famous, Choppa.
Are we doing the TP shit?
Alright, here we go.
No, it's cause he didn't see it, guys.
He just didn't see it.
No, don't say that.
He didn't see it.
Funfuntitobi added me.
I'm lovable.
I'm just a little quirky little guy.
I'm so lovable.
There's no way.
Guys, he didn't see that.
I'm so quirky and lovable.
I refuse to believe.
There's no way.
There's a...
No!
Okay, I sort of threw that.
I sort of threw that.
I wanted to drop down and heal from behind, but then I didn't realize there was a fucking Starlord in our little backline there.
Not fair.
It's not fair.
There's a guy right over here that rezzed.
Please,
keep me up, keep me up.
I got it.
I'm pushing, I'm pushing for it.
No!
Oh, everybody died too fast.
Everybody died too fucking fast.
They feared me.
Why?
I'm just a little guy.
If they knew my record, would they truly fear me though?
If they knew what I've been going through.
They just don't know.
They should not fear me.
I'm just...
I'm just a little guy.
Oh my god, I hit the shots that matter.
Alright, get out, get out.
Let me get out.
He fucking lied to me.
I didn't want it to be...
Nah, they've had him though.
Press one button, foolish me.
That's true.
Starlord's trying to ult.
We're doing it.
Oh, I'm... Oh, we're okay, we're okay.
I don't know.
Strange has ult.
No, I couldn't get my right click.
I couldn't get my fucking right click.
I got it now.
Oh, this is a very scary rez.
This truly is very scary right now.
Oh my god.
I'm ulting this.
Okay.
This is huge.
Oh my god.
We did it.
We lived.
That was so scary.
That was actually so scary.
Holy fuck.
We should not have lived that.
We absolutely should not have lived that, guys.
I don't know how.
But like, I take those.
We still have to do two more minutes of this.
Or four minutes, depending on how fucked up...
There we go.
What the fuck is this?
What the fuck?
Wait, he missed.
How do you miss?
Exactly!
I'm contesting.
He missed.
That's what happened.
We all were like, how did you miss?
Like, all of us were confused.
We all wanted to know how that was possible.
I guess I died.
Yeah, no, he missed.
I'm just as surprised.
Okay, the match is about to finish in like a minute.
Can we finish this in five?
Oh no.
I froze somebody.
Somebody!
Oh, that's a huge ult.
Yeah, shield.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god, I gotta jungle this!
Alright, two more minutes!
Two more minutes!
Alright, I'm bubbling.
Ready, ready, ready.
Here we go.
I need a reload.
Bro, I need a reload.
Oh my!
I'm still looking for it.
Oh my god.
No!
Oh my.
Oh no.
No!
You fucking strange N!
Oh, they born again.
Oh my god.
Oh no, I might be fucking dead.
Oh thank god.
Three, two, one.
I have strange on us.
No!
Guys, go miss my latest Sentinels match, but it's not my fault.
Guys, if any Sentinels fanboys or his team is watching me right now, it is not my fault.
I swear to god.
It's not my fault.
Oh, thank god.
Go miss.
Black quest won.
You're safe.
Wait, what?
Wait, they won?
Yeah, you're safe.
Wait, they won him out?
Yeah.
No way.
Getting dicked on right now.
We're never punished!
Yippee!
Alright.
Let's go!
We're almost fight night.
We're safe!
It's not my fault!
Look how I can't hear what British Tree says because I don't want my feelings to get hurt.
Hahaha!
You guys didn't see that, guys.
It's okay.
Our man has saved me.
Guys, you didn't see it, guys.
Okay, I need to focus.
I need to focus.
I actually need to focus here.
Oh my god.
How the...
How the fuck did they got Mantis ult so fast?
Like, how the fuck?
That's crazy they got Mantis ult that fast.
It's not my fault.
There's someone above.
Oh my god!
Do you have shield?
Oh my god, thank god.
Hi!
Oh my god!
There's a Scyther behind us.
No!
Adam!
No.
This Adam is not good at... at Adam.
This Adam has had a lot of really bad Adam ults.
I'm gonna say it.
Like,
it has definitely not been ideal.
Their Adam has definitely not been playing very well.
It's okay, guys.
It's fine because in the end it's definitely not my fault.
His ult has been really bad.
His ult placement is just...
Placing shields.
Makes sense to shield.
Oh nice, a C9!
Thank god.
I think the EU buff is losing its effect now.
I think so too, guys.
I think so too.
I sort of want to play Adam because their Adam resists are so bad.
They're so bad.
What are you playing?
What are you usually playing?
I'm just playing really bad on mag right now.
Any DPS.
I just think I'm not getting any value right now.
I'm not playing well on mag.
Can you make the Bucky work?
Nah, I'm really good.
They banned it though.
Man, you said you could play any DPS.
What do you mean?
They banned it.
Oh wait, did they?
Okay, now we call out others.
You saw the Adam resists!
They were both bad!
You all saw the Adam resists!
Don't fucking lie to me!
Stop coping!
You all saw the Adam resists!
You cannot say I'm fucking coping when we saw what we saw!
I'll fucking tear you!
Loki 1-8-3.
I don't know if this works, guys.
I think we need the mag.
I think we might need the mag in stream.
Guys,
I don't think this is winnable anymore.
Guys, I think this might be a cheat sheet.
Hehehe.
Oh nice!
Oh my god, they're giving us everything we've ever wanted.
I'm damage boosting.
I got shield.
They have strange ult.
I froze him.
Alright.
Guys, a miracle just happened and then we're gonna lose at the last point, maybe.
I don't know.
I'm trying not to be a doomer.
I'm just trying to have no expectations right now.
So, if we do lose, at least I won't be disappointed.
I smell garlic.
Someone in my house is cooking.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
I'm not the problem.
I am absolutely not a problem there.
Bro, what?
Guys, that's how you actually... that's how you do it.
That's how you do it all.
Oh, why?
Why?
We did not need to use second chance, but okay.
Do a frontline.
Oh my god.
Guys, that's an Adam all right there.
Fear.
Okay, guys.
Seeing that Adamrez, our Adamrez, and also our Strangelove.
All right, guys.
Do you really think I'm coping?
Yeah.
I...
Again.
Oh my... Bro, get out.
I'm not getting my ult in time.
They used my ult in the fight before, but they don't have my ult.
Guys, I'm... I know that I'm doing the best I can.
I mean, you know, I'm just happy to be... to win some... to win at least...
Play up.
We have link.
Watch out for this range behind us.
Keep looking this range.
There's no shield.
We have Luna ult.
All right, here we go.
Oh, thank god.
They definitely have Strangelove, by the way.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I'm not going, I'm not going, I'm not going, I'm not going, I'm not going.
I'm not going, I'm not going, I'm not going.
No more.
Guys, I think this guy is definitely... This guy is a strange player.
We definitely did not have a strange player, guys.
Guys,
I just don't think we had a strange or an Adam player.
We definitely did not.
Yeah, you're fucking dead.
What the hell are you doing?
You don't know how to live.
What the fuck?
That was definitely not my... I know that wasn't my fault.
I know, for real, that that was most definitely not my fault.
Holy fuck.
Oh shit, let's kill.
Wait.
Did you avoid?
Alright, let's try it.
Alright, let's tempt fate again.
Let's fucking tempt fate once again.
He's like, let's try it.
Let's do it.
Let's try again.
Alright, let's see.
Is there anyone online that I can steal?
At least... No, everybody has their own stack, unless I can mooch off of their stack and be like, do you guys want a four stack?
I swear to god, I'm not the problem.
Don't look at my history.
As long as no one else snitches me out, should be fine.
Guys, it's okay.
Look, I'm watching... I'm watching the game right now.
It looks like 100 thieves could potentially get fold held.
So like, that means it could go 2-2, guys.
It could potentially go 2-2, guys.
And you know what that means.
You know what that means, guys.
Potentially.
Yeah, potentially, we'll be okay.
We'll be okay.
This will make me happy.
This will satisfy me for the rest of the night.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
I don't know, like, there's a lot of people that I don't know who sent me requests.
As long as... I'm just gonna put all the eternity players in standby until now.
Oh my god, that... wait, I'm gonna ask, did you avoid our Adam yet?
Our Adam or no?
Cause our Adam was questionable.
Okay, alright, the Adam was not avoided as well, so we're gonna get rid of that guy.
We're gonna get rid of the Adam player as well.
As long as none of these people are on my team, I will be okay.
Guys, how many points did I lose?
I don't wanna check my... I don't wanna check my history right now.
I think I'll cry.
How much... does anyone know how much I lost that last game?
Guys, that last... don't tell me about overall.
Like, I know I lost a lot.
But, like, the last game.
Does anyone know the last game?
How much I lost?
Surely someone in my chat has remembered it.
Surely...
Guys, I'm not talking about... I'm not talking about overall, guys.
Okay, you get it, you fuckers.
Okay, I can't believe it.
Guys, if I sniffle, it's not because I'm crying.
It's just allergies.
Oh.
Oh my god, my allergies are acting up again.
Oh, my allergies.
Oh, my poor allergies, guys.
My poor allergies, they're acting up right now.
Damn, it's hitting hard.
I'm okay.
The pain and sorrow in her voice.
Oh, my god.
There we go.
It's okay, guys.
I'm okay.
Guys, it's... I'm okay.
There's no fixing me, but I'm okay.
Everybody, there's nothing... there's no way to fix this.
This damn ninja slicing onions in your room again.
Yeah.
It's fine.
Oh, look at this.
This will make me happy.
Does, like, the thing have anything?
I'm actually curious.
The thing.
How do I change this?
Change it again.
I don't remember.
How do I change this?
Oh, here you go.
Change heroes.
Alright.
No, it's a little flat.
It's not really... No.
I mean, it's there.
There's the curvature, but it's a little...
No, it's not as perky as I would like it.
I feel like... What about the... Okay, what about Human Torch?
Oh, no.
That's flat as fuck.
He has no ass.
The Human Torch has no ass.
I mean, what about Mr. Fantastic?
Does he have an ass?
Whoa!
I mean...
He chose this.
He chose the size of the butt, basically.
Whoa!
Look at that!
And he, like, snaps his... He, like, snapped it back as well.
Like, the curve here.
He knows what he wants to show.
He could buff it.
True.
What about... Does Punisher have... What about Punisher?
No, he's flat.
No.
No booty.
No cake for him.
How about... Black Panther must have an ass.
Oh!
Wait a minute!
Wow!
Look at that!
The hidden gem!
Damn!
Look at that!
Oh, and he's flaunting it!
You see that?
See how he's like, yeah, I got that.
I got those.
But...
No, but Venom... I think Venom is the best one.
If I have to rate the... If I do a tier list of, like, Marvel rivals' booties, I think Venom is 100%, like, the best one out of all of them.
I think.
Someone's like, check Rocket Raccoon.
That fucking tail is covering it.
We'll never know.
We'll never fucking know.
How about Jeff?
Like, he's a shark, but he's still...
Oh, I guess, like, it doesn't... When they have... They get, like, a tail debuff, I guess.
When you have a tail, it gets debuffed, so you don't really have an ass after that.
What about...
No, it's pretty flat.
No.
I don't know.
I mean, it looks like...
It's like a canyon in between.
It's just, like, the distance between the two is a little too far.
Alright, who do we have?
Alright, who's in my team?
We have... Oh, JessieJudoMan!
We have JessieJudoMan.
I always... I trust Jessie.
Jessie... Wait, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Okay, and then he's a 6.
Okay, JessieJudoMan.
Jessie... I have no idea who some of these people are.
Only conquers worthy winners.
You have to regain your worth in Rivals.
They want...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm banning Groot.
I don't fucking care.
I don't know if... Guys, I don't know if... Guys, guys.
If Gomez is late for his tournament, it's not my fault.
He said requeue.
Guys, it's not my fault.
Oh
no.
It's okay.
It'll be okay.
All right, we just got Mantis.
No, Jessie, you got it, bro.
All you.
Literally, we just... We literally just switched damage boosting Luna and Loki off.
And we team wiped them.
Easy.
It's not my fault.
No, no.
Sometimes things are my fault.
But in this particular instance, he said requeue.
And I was like, okay.
I can play Thing instead of Mantis so we can group tank.
And that is up to you guys.
It's not my fault.
When is it my fault?
Guys, look, today is definitely not my fault.
Guys, please.
It only takes one bad day.
I approve with no water.
It only takes one bad day to make me... Guys, please.
You don't want to know what happens when I get to that day.
Wait, wait, fireman.
Fireman, watch out.
Fireman.
What the fuck is fireman doing here?
Whoa.
Whoa, careful.
Yeah, we got it all.
What?
I did not expect that.
Did they have a Hawkeye?
No, the...
Their Human Torso did 300 damage to me.
Whoa, the buff.
Wait, those buffs actually made him good.
Oh, there's a Sidelock on me?
They added two extra power buffs.
What the hell?
I'm hurt.
Where's Sidelock at?
I'm sorry, hold on.
The Sidelock is still behind us.
Yo, Sidelock, why did we wake him?
Because I didn't expect you to sleep him.
The Sidelock is still doing Sidelock things.
He's dead.
Oh.
Mantis first?
I froze somebody.
Wait, Megwin, Megwin!
Oh, he's still there.
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
I'm walking up, I'm walking up.
4, 3, 2, 1.
Meg is low.
Meg won.
Wait,
they only have one support.
Okay, I'm on open mic now.
Wait, I am...
Are those buffs live?
Yeah.
Wait, they have two supports now, they have two supports.
Oh, they fixed it.
Oh my god, the building fucking rebuilt itself!
Wait, Meg is low.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Yeah, yeah, I like that.
Oh my god.
Maltus?
There's a Sidelock behind us.
Yeah, fuck that Luna in particular.
Megwin, Megwin!
There's a Sidelock left.
Sidelock's one.
They have Hella now.
Oh my god.
I'm so... I can't make funny haha commentary, I'm too focused.
Like, what is going on?!
I hear the Sidelock around me.
He's roaming.
There's a Sidelock on cart.
Oh, he got up.
He's half.
Oh my god!
We're okay, we're okay, we're okay, we're okay.
That's a big dodge killer!
What the fuck was that?!
Oh my god.
Holy shit, that scared the shit out of me.
Me team is a joke.
Oh my god.
I was just smiling and the fucking Sidelock came out of nowhere.
I'm like, holy fuck.
I'm surprised we all lived there.
I'm actually so surprised we managed to live there.
That was fucking wild.
That was fucking... that was wild.
Wait, we banned pro-Styler and he started...
At least...
That's insane.
I messed him up.
That's crazy.
Guys, that's actually crazy.
Oh, I didn't mess it up.
Oh, I cooked.
No, they're out, they're out.
No, no, only a few of them though.
Oh, I see, I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm emoting.
Wait, he's out, he's out.
Who are the E-Daters?
I greeted, I greeted, I greeted.
We're the E-Daters on our team.
Yeah, who are they?
So we can avoid.
I mean, I avoided JonCelo.
Is he that bad?
No, he just doesn't like me.
Blames me.
Yeah,
bro.
Team mentality is very important.
Oh, I played Jeff on Spider Island.
I didn't do that good, to be fair.
But like, our team went like, everyone negative.
And everyone just decided to blame me.
I mean, you were on Jeff, that's like the number one thing to blame.
Yeah, I know, but here's the thing.
Our Infest had 19k healing.
I had 15k.
And my entire ults were being countered by freaking Mag.
And I still had more kills.
Like, it was insane to blame me.
Wait, wait, hold on, hold on, I might die.
Okay, yeah, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's cook that.
We'll do it.
I think he's dead, I think...
Okay.
Alright, let's do it.
Ready, ready, stack.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, wait, wait, okay, that's all three, it's all...
We used three subpoenas.
That's so funny, that's so funny.
Okay, guys, I don't think anything can save us now.
I think we used...
You know what, do you think we can outrun it with Mantisult?
No, I don't have Mantisult.
No, we just use one ult, die, and then save another subpoena.
Oh, are they Bucky?
Are they Mantis?
Wait, not Mantis, they, uh...
They use all DPS ults, they...
I don't know, I feel like if I ult, I'm outrunning them.
Like, I'm losing.
I don't know, because I know it's sexual.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you guys may die, you guys may die, but I'm outrunning you.
Yo, that was a great ult, that was a great ult, we all saw that.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you ulted?
I definitely just didn't hit 5 or anything.
I think it was a support diff there, we actually helped you out.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Oh,
goodbye.
Yeah, I'm a DPS.
There is a Captain America on your supports right now.
Oh, it's okay, he ran away.
Alright, we need a cap point.
How are they all dead again?
Why are you guys so much better than them?
Alright, they're gonna, they're gonna rez.
Alright, they're gonna do the Wombo Combo maybe, alright?
Let's be ready here.
Watch out TP, watch out TP!
Oh shit!
Oh, we're still playing!
Okay, they see 9.
Wait, we did it guys!
GG's everybody!
Go to your tournament!
Gomez, go team!
That was, that was a good game!
Okay, not gonna lie.
Not, not gonna lie.
If anything, I think that has to be the game that we call it.
That was, that was a really good game.
I think that has to be the best game to like, call it in general.
Because it was, it was a really good final game.
And, I get to stay on the leaderboard!
Let's go!
Yeah, that's crazy!
We all, we did three support ults and we still died!
That's actually fucking crazy!
We all stacked each other and we didn't even survive it!
Oh my god!
Yeah, it was a good game with good teammates and like, good bonding time.
We actually talked, we actually, you know, had a good time with our teammates and actually talked with each other.
That was crazy.
That was crazy fun, though.
Oh my god.
It's alright.
I had a great time.
Three support ults versus Unstoppable Journey.
Okay, anyway guys, I hope you all had a great time watching.
I'm glad that we ended it on a high note there.
Okay, so yeah, anyway.
Speaking of Marble Rivals, starting next week, depending on whenever it's finalized, I'll be back to streaming on Twitch for Marble Rivals Grinds.
Because we'll be working together with Rivals soon!
Yay!
But that also means...
That also means I have to stream Marble Rivals consistently.
And I don't want to do most of my Rank Grind on YouTube.
So we will be back playing Rank on Twitch, maybe starting next week.
And it'll just be whenever I have the time.
So yeah, anyway, I'm glad we ended it on a high note.
It started off very rough.
And then we started believing.
And now I know I'm not the problem.
And that's all that matters to me.
Anyway, guys.
We made it to a high note.
That last game was such a good game.
That was actually such a good game to end it on.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!